Club that comes from our famous
Chicago.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net don't have to give you one of them.
I never did right now.
We gave you one.
Uh,
I bought my own [inaudible] you had the uh,
you never gave me one.
No.
Did you tell the story on the podcast ever did I did?
Yeah,
I did.
Yeah.
That's a good flashlight story.
But we can tell the same story twice.
Yeah.
Some girl basically Clifton all grow wouldn't fuck him.
He took her to a,
a porn shop.
I bought a flashlight while she was staying with them.
It's hilarious.
And then that's the worst feeling in the world.
We are like really attract to a chicken really into her.
And then you come like whether you jerk off or something and then you just like
what?
Posted on syndrome.
[inaudible] Syndrome.
[inaudible] syndrome is huge,
man.
That's life changing shit.
You realize how much your Dick is kidnapping your,
your whole brain.
You don't learn that Shit Til like 20 or thirties.
And when you finally figured out you got kids,
you got finally figured out,
Oh shit.
Like no matter how much you think you want to fuck a chick,
man,
when you bust that nut,
the truth comes out.
And she said,
you remember that bit?
You had one of the big long bus.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's what it's like when you dig is hard.
When you're in normal life to bit was like in normal life you're driving,
you're,
you're in control.
You're at the wheel.
You decide which way you go when your Dick is hard.
It's like you're sitting in the backseat of a really long bus and then some
other dude up there and driving is way the fuck up there.
And he could barely talk to him as long as,
eh,
all this noise.
And you're like,
do you even know where you're going?
You'll shut the fuck up and sit up.
And He'd just go,
oh,
this guy's a dick.
I'm just going to go to sleep and post nuts.
Syndromal well,
you know,
once you,
you figure it out,
it's like a,
it's almost like a trick is total trick because if you're not in like
maintenance mode,
if you're not taking care of yourself,
you're not jerking off on a regular basis.
You can get frantic.
Like guys can get frantic.
Like someone needs to touch my deck.
Somebody needs to try to predict.
Like if you go like a couple of weeks without beating off and then you're around
someone you're attracted to,
it's we literally become insane.
He become like an insane person.
Man.
I don't know how many times I've,
I could have banged a chick now,
this is when I was single,
my single years.
Uh,
I could have banged a chick and I thought about the Postman Syndrome and I
thought,
you know what?
I really,
really,
really want to fuck her right now,
but dammit,
let me just jerk off.
You bust a nut.
You're like,
Dang God,
thank God,
thank God I didn't call that like right away.
You know,
that'll cure you.
You drink.
If you jerk off and you still want to see the check,
then you read lagger in love.
Yeah.
You really like,
or if you bust a nut and you don't want to throw her out the fucking window,
you probably like her.
Do you want to go get some lunch?
If you want to go get lunch after you bust them,
not you want to go watch a movie or something you really liked.
It is a real problem in relationships that nobody wants to own up to and that
problem is that women are essentially drug dealers and that drug is pussy and
it's the best Raga Earth.
It's,
you know when you're horny and you're getting some posts and you're like,
I can't even believe I'm getting pussy here.
When you're having sex,
you're like,
I can't believe this is even happening because you wanted it so bad and you,
especially if you've been on a dry spell,
like what's your longest dry spell like in high school and shit.
Ever.
Ever in life.
Damn Dude.
I don't know.
That's a long time.
I used to work at a strip club.
There wasn't that many dry spells.
I had a six month one when I was 19 it was devastating.
That was a long one.
Then when you're a teenager,
I remember the dry spells being so long thinking man I like,
I would fantasize about what the next girl I'm gonna fuck would look like and
what you're going to be like.
Is it going to be six months?
Is it going to be a year and a half?
I mean I would think like it was like a fantasy thing,
you know like
that was way back in the day.
Way Back in the day before you discovered this is a place where they grow.
They just grow on trees over here.
You know in high school you get to know girls,
you get to meet girls,
you know you date,
but once you get out of high school if you're not,
you know you're not in college.
Like my first year of college out of high school,
I didn't do anything.
I just work my first year before I went to school again.
And that was when I just went through my most devastating ever drought cause
like I'm never around girls.
So you have no chance.
Yeah.
It sucks for people that are like that work at places where there's no checks.
You're there all day and then you live in a town where there's hardly no chicks
in those towns where if there's a hot chick in town,
by the time she's 16 dudes are already proposing and like locked in.
There's no way you're going to go into a small town and there's going to be a
super hottie that's 22,
that single no,
good luck.
Small town.
No good luck.
Somebody to college down.
Yes.
Unless she just broke up.
And then even then the dude's still coming around the house yelling drunk at
night.
You need,
Dude's just knocked those bitches out.
Fuck it.
Let's just,
they don't want to even,
cause they know everyone around them is trying to get a piece of that.
This is supposed to be a commercial for the question.
I think it's still going.
So,
uh,
so that's where in the code name Rogan and get 15% off.
Well,
this,
it all comes back fleshlight well,
we've been doing commercials like this and people have been complaining because
they're so long.
But I'm like,
but it's sort of not even really a commercial.
I mean,
it's a commercial.
I'm talking about the flashlight,
but we're also just talking,
you know,
it's organic.
Instead of me reading some canned bullshit,
you only can bullshit part is a part where I got to say,
you know,
15% off entering the codename Rogan.
I should that every time.
You know,
it'd be cool for the fleshlight is if they sold like mannequins that you could
just like,
just stick the flashlight and,
and fucking you in when you're done.
You Paul fleshlight out just like a real doll.
Yeah.
But it's just,
it's sitting up,
there's one bent over and you just like stick that bless light and hit it.
You know what I mean?
Definitely help with that.
Even help.
I mean,
how much can you use your imagination?
Can you really pretend that that's a person?
I think that would help.
Yeah,
I think it would help because then you cause you actually fuck it and stick your
hand nuts feel different when you're thrusting.
Yeah,
totally feel different when you're trusting them.
More impact behind them.
Yeah.
The sensation is,
is like 20% difference just ran out.
Coma patients.
Oh boy.
They used to have a joke about the Veggie hookers,
like super low cost hookers.
They're like vegetables and you just
like,
how much would a vegetable because you know to help pay for the,
it's not cheap.
It's not cheap.
You know,
keeping him on life support.
Yeah,
that's what I'm,
you know what I mean?
For the hospital because they don't have insurance.
They have no choice.
Dude.
Veggie hookers,
it'd be like five bucks and they deliver them.
Do you like as a dude?
Wheels admitted in a hospital going to hire somebody to clean them all day in
between sessions.
They couldn't tell on you.
That would have to be somebody watching and make sure you don't abuse them.
Put cigarettes out.
Hey,
you know what?
Cause otherwise hookers can complain.
That can't even talk.
We can't even talk.
So maybe somebody else
she can move your eyes was like,
fuck yeah,
this guy says creepy shit to her while shooting in.
Imagine pulling trains on Veggie hookers,
cod.
Oh,
you gotta do what?
You got to get better.
It's better than jerking off,
right?
No,
no,
no.
Cause you're thinking about this poor paralyzed person.
Yeah.
The puss,
that syndrome would be so big.
Just dress him up.
They'll put like sunglasses on him and like a nice like,
you know,
nightgown or so what's fucked up?
Told them,
you know,
there's somebody that I know there's somebody that's into that,
there's,
there's gotta be gotta be this gotta be Brian.
Um,
they asked him to do a fucking video where him and his girl are tied up.
Yeah.
I tie him up in film,
struggling to get free.
Like if we were kidnapped together and we're in fucking imagine them am still
thinking about it,
but I think it might do it myself.
How much they should find out what everybody who wants and fire.
Amen.
Okay.
They should find out anybody,
anybody who buys those videos,
they should follow that motherfucker.
You know,
find out where he gets his duct tape when he uses it on.
What the fuck is going on here?
That's what you're buying.
You're buying videos at dude's tied up with their girl.
The fuck on a weird ideas that you have in your head.
You have to be tied up and your girl damn well she gets 500 I get 400 but how do
you know this guy's to fucking untie you?
I didn't know this guy's [inaudible],
but what I'm saying is I company,
yeah,
it's a porn porn or now a bondage company.
Jesus Christ.
Oh shit son.
Where did you go?
Wrong site.
And what I'm thinking is like,
dude,
I could just fill them up myself,
make it better and then just throw it like on clips for sale.com or whatever and
just,
I'm sure when people sell that direct membership,
like a subscription link to all the creepy fuck yeah.
You know,
they have their email addresses,
they can just send them out to all the creepy fucks up by their bondage videos
right away.
You have to find that market anyway.
We're
also sponsored by ana.com.
Makers of Alpha brain.
This is the longest.
This is the last one ever.
So Alpha brain is a cognitive enhancing supplement.
We also have new mood,
which is a five HTP and l trip to fan supplement.
Five HTP or a lot of controversy.
Man,
a lot of people use it as an antidepressant.
And a,
um,
a buddy of mine who was on it,
actually,
Neil Brennan was on it and he,
he's,
uh,
he talked about on the podcast and he,
um,
his doctor told him to not take it anymore,
not take the five HTP because essentially what he was doing was taking two
antidepressants,
which I thought was really interesting,
you know?
Yeah.
As doctor told them to stay on these fucking medic medication instead of these
natural herbs that work just as good that you can get without a prescription.
I mean,
that's really essentially what you're saying.
five HTP is a,
you can get it in any health food store.
Right.
You know,
it's a common up.
So what happens is you get to then is the credit card companies scared that
you'd like cancel all your credit cards are like,
well the Pharmaceutical Cup,
but he's scared that you're not going to pay for their shit anymore.
You're not gonna pay for Prozac or Zoloft steady going to pay for five HTP.
It's really interesting.
I don't know,
obviously I don't,
I don't take an antidepressant,
so obviously I don't know what the effect of either one of them has,
but I do know that for me,
who doesn't need an antidepressant?
Five HTP is nice.
I like it.
Neil Neil Brennan turned me onto it first and then this with the difference
between five HTP,
normal in this new mood,
stuff that we're selling is they would also have el trip to fan in it,
which breaks down to Serotonin's like the building blocks
for Turkey,
five HTP.
So what makes you tired and Turkey and I just remembered that and I just took
two and now I'm going to be,
you'll be fine.
You'll be fine.
I take them before I go to sleep though.
Remember that was a sketch to for [inaudible] syndrome was like Zoloft that you
take when you're fucking a chick that you know that you know,
you take the pill and you don't take her out to lunch,
they'll catch a movie eventually they're going to have pills that recreate
orgasms.
You know they're going to have pills.
That isn't that,
that's almost ecstasy.
They almost got sort of right actually on the right there on the right track.
Probably better
in the mind.
Just you don't feel it in your deck.
You know,
it's like a better feeling almost when you're on ecstasy then coming except your
Dick doesn't get the wild ride.
Right.
Does that make sense?
Um,
anyway,
go to [inaudible] dot com enter the Code Day Rogan and you get 10% off.
We also have a shroom tech sport which I got to give you.
It's based on a quarter steps mushroom and it's a,
an endurance Sapa and it's nice,
it gives you energy man,
but not like not wild energy like a coffee or anything like that.
And it gives you like a smooth,
steady energy.
The Chinese Olympics team started using it.
There's a bunch of different cordyceps mushroom supplements out there.
They'll again,
endurance enhancing supplements.
Can I use that to get on?
What about the Germans?
What are they using?
I don't know.
Chinese to do too well,
and they love bags.
I shouldn't say that.
First of all,
the Cambodian,
they're listening.
They're listening.
They're going to get angry.
You know what?
Chinese are wrangling gymnastics.
Oh Shit.
Those,
Oh yeah.
But uh,
they don't feel well with a basketball.
Football,
football,
football.
Mexicans even do better than Chinese and football.
At least we got one Mexican in there right now.
There's a Mexican playing football.
One Guy Sanchez.
He's the quarterback for the jets.
We got one dude.
How many dudes do you think a train is that like a killer thing?
Fuck Mexicans love football.
They're just too small.
So it was just made it,
I mean,
I figured that out in the ninth grade when I got to ninth grade,
I'm like,
God damn does the end of this commercial and the music
experience [inaudible] those along.
But whatever.
It's not really commercial telling you some stories in there.
Right.
Some shit going down and he did sample edgy.
Bravo.
My friend Eddie Bravo is here.
Thank you for having me.
Thank you.
Joe Diaz was supposed to be here with us,
but Joe Rogan,
I got the other things I gotta do.
I'm going to be there at nine o'clock.
I'm going to be there at nine o'clock so Joey will be here when we do another
podcast.
Actually never.
He actually never agreed to do it.
He never did it.
Yeah.
I thought he was going to do it.
I twittered it.
I tweeted it and he calls me up and tells him like,
man,
you don't know anything unless you're talking to me.
I'm like,
Oh shit.
I thought I did agree to it.
He agreed it to me.
Joey's crazy.
It's okay.
You got,
I got things I gotta do dog.
Yeah.
You know what?
I shouldn't have jumped the gun now.
I shouldn't have jumped the gun and tweeting it.
Yeah,
because he,
cause everyone laughs.
Everybody's scared.
Joey's got everybody.
Security can even tweet things that you said he would do.
What the fuck you're doing?
What the fuck did I tell you to tweak that?
The fuck you do tweet tweeting that he's the best though.
I fucked.
I don't mind.
No,
you didn't fuck up.
You fucked up in the world of Joey and the regular world where you did was
normal.
He told me he was going to do it.
He then he said to me on the phone today,
do you want me to do these things dog,
you gotta talk to me a day before I did talk to you Dave,
before we talked about it yesterday.
But you know these Joey d hopefully he comes tonight.
He's going to come tonight.
He just doesn't want to be here all day.
But you know when he might not come tonight.
I mean he reserves the right to not show up.
That's done twice or three times.
Yeah,
he just doesn't show up sometimes.
Luckily it doesn't matter.
He's so,
he's such a wild motherfucker.
That's why you like him cause he's so random.
It doesn't matter.
He could flake on three shows.
Four shows you still love them?
Well,
it took me,
no,
not really that long to realize that you don't get a personality like that
without some quirks,
you know?
Uh,
personally,
I mean,
that's just the impulsiveness of the reason why it's so funny.
You know,
it's all just his,
his own special blend,
his own special personality,
you know,
let's just,
uh,
he's just an unusual dude and you gotta accept that you've got to let him be who
he is.
That's why I started taking two comics on the road with me.
I used to only take one,
but that one was Joey.
A lot of time and a lot of time,
Joe,
who just fucking,
he just would vanish on you.
And
so I started taking other dudes.
Yeah.
So it became two and then I realized when you take two,
it's more fun anyway,
you know,
becomes like a party,
like one dude is good,
but when you go on the road with like two,
three dudes,
that's when it becomes really fun.
You know,
it doesn't feel bad.
And like when we go on the road,
you,
Eddie should go on the road with us all the time for years,
for years,
and when we would go on the road,
you know,
it never felt like we weren't home.
It just,
we had different places where we slept,
but everything else is the same,
was just all our friends going out to eat,
all our friends,
you know,
drinking or whatever.
All our friends at the shows,
it seems to me like we were just hanging out,
which is beautiful,
but you never,
you know,
you don't get that horrible fucking loneliness that a lot of comics get when
they go on the road.
Man.
They just,
them alone in a hotel room after the show,
just wishing they were home,
missing their girl,
missing their dog,
just desperate.
There's a lot of dudes gets fucking seriously depressed from road traveling.
I can imagine,
man,
I hate being gone just for two or three days.
Can you imagine being like I Heffron that's like gone for like a whole month
almost something.
He's crying.
He doesn't bring guys with them.
He's not going with a bunch of his buddies and guys with them.
Why does it sound good?
Actually it's on a non gay guy and he doesn't bring guys with them.
Yes.
I don't know why I even thought like that.
Sad,
sad.
You would think that way.
That's where all this Todd comics either comics out there,
they're like bring checks with them everywhere they go.
Sure.
Yeah,
yeah,
absolutely.
There's one shot or something.
There's one comic that did our podcast.
I knew it was going to bring his fucking wife.
He brings her everywhere.
Dude.
I've never seen him without her.
She's really hot and he's really not and he's like,
I got this bitch.
She ain't going nowhere.
And he just brings her everywhere.
Everywhere they go.
And he brought her on the podcast and she,
we had to get her a microphone.
She was talking.
So wait,
hold on.
I'm going to turn the microphone.
It's like she kept on talking off mic.
So it was constant,
like just,
here's my,
yeah,
it was,
well it wasn't,
it wasn't reluctant.
I like her.
She's nice.
She's,
you know,
she's not stupid.
She's smart person,
but it's just,
he's just one of those dudes that just can't,
he doesn't go anywhere without his girl.
Yeah.
People do that man.
Probably listening to the show and that's okay.
We didn't say anything bad.
It's all true.
He's a great guy.
I love him.
Hey Eddie,
I did you release a new music video recently or have you released it yet or
what's going on with that?
That music video?
We were going to release it last week,
but it turns out it's,
there's still some color colorization left to do some technical shit,
but we're going to drop it,
uh,
Travie first or second week of December.
Awesome.
We're going to have,
but I can't wait to see it.
It's,
it's pretty dope man.
What's the song?
It's Jujitsu.
Did you redo the song's called Jujitsu?
The song's called Dj.
Did you Redo the whole song?
Did you,
cause you had an original song right now.
Did you redo it or what,
what,
what did you change?
What happened?
Um,
Rocka who is a rapper for dilated peoples?
He does Jujitsu with Hannah and Hiran and we had a mutual friend,
his name was um,
a DC and he's like,
dude man,
I'm going to Hook you on rock up together.
You guys make music together.
We kept talking about it for like a year would call me.
He goes,
well weren't Hollywood where you at?
I wasn't there.
Then after a year he finally,
we finally link up,
he ends up at my studio and I,
you know,
I had some songs,
I was gonna you know,
some,
some tracks I was going to play for them.
I had three of them and he was going to choose which one he wanted to throw a
verse over and that was the first plan.
But like,
you know,
what do we sing about or what does the song going to be about?
And I thought,
you know,
since he's here,
cause the Dessa kept going to do you know what's happening.
That's,
he's deep with the Gracies with hunter and Horian on or all of them and your 10
planet,
you guys coming together with music and he's like,
is it a big deal?
And I thought,
well,
why don't we,
why doesn't the song just be called Jujitsu?
We just,
uh,
you know,
any rat dude,
I don't know if you heard it,
but,
no,
that is his verse.
When he dropped it played him some beats.
He,
it took him about 45 minutes to write the verses,
boom.
And then compel her.
The guy that gets in my band,
who I always work with an Alex,
were on the side working on adverse verse two,
so that we ended up just going,
why don't you tee rocket,
take the first verse,
compel it,
took the second and Alex did the third.
And
will it be fun for people who don't do Jujitsu?
Do you think about that?
You just say,
fuck it.
Let's just do it.
For us,
it's,
it's really all about,
you know,
the,
to me,
my opinion,
the best music is when it's personal.
When it's like,
if you're trying to write a to,
you know,
so that people can relate to it.
That's in my case at an,
in my opinion,
I think that that's garbage.
I think that's how it is.
Everything.
Yeah.
You gotta write,
you gotta end.
It was just perfect because that's what it was about.
He showed up and were like,
man,
it is the Gracies rep 10 planet coming together.
So the song is about bearing like any kind of negative emotions or negative
energy that there is with 10 planted in the,
let's just bury that shit.
It's all about Jujitsu.
We love it.
And it's,
you know,
and that's,
that's how we ended up doing a music video for it.
And Ken Mau edited it and,
and he made it look really damn good man.
Um,
he,
he's done.
He was,
he's dead.
Beyonce videos.
Jay Z foo fighters.
Anybody you could think of.
He want an MTV music award for crazy by GNARLS Barkley.
That was awesome.
Cut that video.
Wow.
He got cut.
He cut.
He's like the baddest motherfucker on the business and he cut my video.
That was one of my favorite walkin music's ever.
When Bj Penn came into that song,
I'm like,
how perfect is that for Bj [inaudible] you can hear the audio.
We released the audio,
the,
I'm the songs actually we mean me and rocket did it.
And then I got Danny loaner from nine inch nails.
He,
he actually produced it.
Was that like,
was that like a dream come true getting Danny?
Cause that's,
I mean I,
both of us were huge nine inch nails fan still are.
I mean nine inch nails was like,
that's my,
that's my blood and here I am.
Yeah.
You know,
working with Danny Loner,
it's pretty fucking crazy.
Every time I'm at his house,
he's got a student in high school,
like a castle mansion up in Hollywood hills and I'm sitting there and we're
working on some shit.
It's,
you know,
it's just,
it's awesome.
Finally,
after all this time,
getting the respect to them in the music business that,
that I wanted,
you know,
and it was hard cause most people thought I was an athlete,
a Jujitsu guy who
is dabbling in music now,
like Oscar de la Hoya or like,
you know,
Shaq or something.
They don't realize that I started Jujitsu at 24 and I've been producing music my
whole life.
That's was the number one goal.
Jujitsu with just a way to stay in shape.
And most people don't realize realize that so they have,
they have a prejudice against my music.
Then I didn't want to hear the music.
Oh my God,
you get two guys trying to do music now.
They don't realize that this is what,
this is what I'm really good at now it though,
I mean there's a reason why they say that and it's because almost everybody only
does one thing good.
And they'll go and do something else and it sucks.
You know,
like how many times there's an actor put out an album and it's fucking terrible.
The odds,
the odds.
I mean,
I understand.
So I understand the odds.
I mean,
I wouldn't,
you remember when Michael Jordan tried to play baseball?
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
I remember that.
Yep.
Barely.
Yeah.
It didn't last long,
right?
It was everyone.
Don Johnson was a singer.
I went,
Don Johnson was a senator.
Don Johnson had songs.
Yeah,
currently are terrible.
They were terrible.
The audio is actually available now.
The,
the video,
we're not going to drop for a couple of weeks.
It's almost done.
The audio is available@reverbnation.com slash smoke serpent.
That's the name of the band,
smoke serpent.
So we got a couple songs on there.
The 2011 version of dropped,
which is pretty dope as well.
But um,
the video will be allowed to call your own stuff.
Dope.
Fuck yeah.
You have to be careful about that now.
Now when it,
when it comes down,
you know,
every band,
when their album comes out,
they go,
man,
this is our best shit.
It's awesome you,
no one ever says,
man,
my new album's coming out.
It's,
it's I,
no,
no.
I know what I'm saying at all.
I'm saying,
you know,
you,
it's,
it's hard to judge your own shit without looking strange,
isn't it?
Isn't that hard to,
no,
not music.
It is the comedy.
It's comedy.
You know,
you say,
I did.
This is my best stuff ever.
But that's about it.
If you're getting in any more detail and say it's fucking awesome,
it cracks,
it sizzles.
Music's different.
It pops.
Yeah.
Music's different.
Really.
Yeah,
for sure.
Well,
it's also maybe because you work with a bunch of people too.
It's like a collaborative effort.
Whereas with comedy you just kind of bragging about yourself.
Yep.
You know,
that's tricky,
right?
Yeah.
But yeah,
I mean,
do you ever make a video and tell everybody how awesome it is?
I never say it's awesome,
but I definitely just go,
hey,
watch my video.
But I don't think I ever say,
you know,
like,
oh my God,
this is the best video I've ever made.
Or something like that.
Video dominates this videos with music that's a little bit more personal and
also it's a bunch of people together,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
Project.
Yeah.
I'm always real careful about any,
any grandiose exclamations about anything that I do.
Cause it always feels like if I talk about it at all,
it makes me feel like a Douche bag.
Yeah,
I understand what music though.
It's,
you gotta be super confident with your music and you know,
without blowing smoke up your own ass.
I actually believe the music that,
that,
you know,
especially the songs,
Jujitsu,
I think it's a great time.
You have to be confident in everything you do.
If you got to do standup,
you have to be confident.
You can't fake fake it with competence.
You know,
technical competence.
You gotta you gotta be in the fucking groove when you're a comic.
What are you playing buddy?
His new song that it,
this is the old version.
This is the demo.
This was on your,
uh,
smoke serpent page on reverbnation.
Thank you.
They don't have the new version of [inaudible].
No,
that's,
he was,
he's fucking with you all.
I was,
no,
I wasn't,
I thought you said it was the new version.
Come on,
come on.
Oh,
drop 2011 and what you're talking about that a time river.
Yeah,
that's onto,
but that's not the song that Danny Lonna priced.
Right.
We actually are working on a Daniel owner version of that song too,
which is totally different.
It's like,
Oh,
you're not even recognize it or just it's,
it's pretty crazy now.
In this day and age,
there's no more music business like there was before.
Is it better for you because there's not like there's no record sales anymore.
That shit's out the window.
It's like I tune sales and concert promotion,
right?
Yep.
It's way better for the musician for sure.
Absolutely.
You get your shit.
Is it better to try to get in?
Is it better this way than it was before?
It was.
He goes the way it was before.
It was very difficult to break into the music business.
Right,
and you'd get leads.
These crazy contracts.
Look,
I remember Courtney love wrote some article about it,
about how,
how crazy though the financial breakdown is of like who owns what and where the
money goes and how long it is before artists actually start getting paid.
It's pretty,
it's pretty brutal,
but it's not like that anymore.
It the odds are,
I mean it's totally in favor now of the artists,
but still,
you know,
I mean it helps being signed to a major label.
They still have all the avenues to get your stuff on MTV if you know.
But you know,
now you can,
you know,
put your stuff on iTunes in the whole world has access to it instantly from
their phone.
That is massive for the artist.
Yeah.
Now it's just about publicizing your shit.
Now it's about letting,
cause I don't know about it exactly what's going on.
Let us know when you're a,
when you're going to release the whole thing.
And we're gonna release a CD on iTunes.
Yes.
What we're releasing the single the singles as we're done with them.
So right now,
so far we have Jujitsu.
We have one song,
you can get it for free right now.
Once the video is out,
um,
you know,
then I'm going to put on iTunes and it's gonna be like a dollar 29 or whatever
the hell it is.
But right now I'm just letting people have it for free for a couple of weeks on
reverbnation powerful,
powerful Internet.
Yeah.
To look just like that.
It's amazing.
Listen to this podcast and nobody ever gave me a radio show.
I had talked about doing a radio show forever cause I would go and sit in on
people's radio shows,
you know,
and it would be fun like you know Dale Dudley and Austin or open Anthony or
something like that.
You know,
it's always a good time.
It's fun to just sit and even doing censored radio where you're,
you're going there and you're,
you know,
you're talking with,
you're making sure you don't swear and you know certain subjects can't even
breach,
you know,
like they told us last time that we couldn't say retard.
Remember that was the last
one that was,
yeah.
That's a new word that's been recently eliminated from the vocabulary of things
you can say and not regular radio is brutal man.
Have you seen that?
That censored version of
tropic thunder?
Remember that whole retard part?
Oh yeah.
No.
What is it?
You can't go full special.
You went full special.
Oh no it does.
He goes no and full specialness.
What's go full special?
Was it just like on TV it's really bad.
Like the over double that is actually even more offensive because special
implies that the person has like down syndrome or something like that.
Retard is just,
you're,
you're a fucking idiot.
You know someone's a retard.
They're a fucking idiot,
but it actually ends in tropic thunder.
It wasn't even,
it wasn't actually was that it was actually about down.
It was.
It actually was retired.
He went full retard.
She says Christ.
That was hilarious.
You finally saw it.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You didn't see three in the class.
That's great.
Everybody in tropic thunder's a douchebag.
Nobody is cooling it.
Right.
Ben Stiller made that Ben Stiller made that whole thing himself.
He's a bad mother fucker.
They need direct that,
something like that.
He's a bad motherfucker.
That was,
that was come earlier.
Every character was great movie.
It was a great movie.
The whole thing.
It was just enough over the top.
Just enough silly,
you know?
You know when I knew it was fucking going to be the greatest movie ever is when
that Dude's head blew up,
the director,
what is that fucking blew up?
I'm like,
Oh shit.
That go on that way and that scared the fuck out no limit.
It's like,
you know,
pineapple express where it's a comedy,
but people are fucking get in their heads blown off.
You know what I mean?
That's,
that's,
that's a whole definitely common scene.
I still haven't seen pineapple express.
Not as good as tropic thunder.
Tropic thunder was so hard to be like,
the only thing that could be tropic thunder and get closed like Talladega nights
or hangover or something like that.
And you know,
Robert Downey playing that dude black makeup on.
I mean,
come on,
it was so crazy.
He's got black makeup on,
he's in the fucking jungle and he's still got black band.
Got Bar.
What was the deal with that guy?
Did he have his pig?
Is,
is um,
is
to his role?
So he just became a black guy,
right?
But did he become,
did he change his pigment?
Which wore makeup everywhere?
Just everywhere I went.
You know,
there are dudes like that that they'll like get in a role and then the entire
time they're working on the set,
like when they're talking to the grips or whatever,
they talk in character,
you know,
hey,
they weren't even shooting.
And he was like,
he kept on and on the right will you get out of this goddamn character?
Why don't you come though,
man?
I don't,
I don't drop character until I do commentary for the DVD.
Wow.
What the fuck?
It was funny when he said it.
Of course.
Yeah.
Generally,
generally Jack Black movies,
I'm not really that into generally in school of rock was good.
Did you see that?
Yeah,
that was,
that was all right.
Like Nacho Libra,
I'm not,
I wasn't a fan read back like we had that one.
Me,
we walked out of that in 20 minutes.
I did not like that movie.
That was about it as a blanket.
No,
just because you guys only took it 10 minutes.
You only give it 10 minutes for like that.
Whatever it was.
Let's call it 15.
It was brutal,
but he was first 50 was killing the fuck.
I said no me had Ari both days.
Yeah.
You went hard bolts that we were barbecued.
Yeah,
we were frazzled.
Still wasn't good cause cause my girlfriend really likes you because you got to
watch it again and sometimes you even want something again like anchor man.
The second time was better.
I'm like way better first time.
Like I didn't really didn't get it,
but um,
he was,
Jack Black was incredible and tropic thunder,
he was incredible man.
I thought,
damn,
he's just killing Larry's.
Yeah.
He was great.
But Robert Downey jr took it from me and you know,
Ben Stiller was really funny and it's was a good fucking movie man.
And we're all really snapped that many good movies,
man.
It's a lot.
When you look at like great movies too.
Shit movies,
it's probably like 10 shit movies to one great one,
right?
Yeah,
dude,
there's so many big actors in that movie.
They probably got paid 50 grand deed or sound.
There's just too many actors.
Danny Mcbride was in it.
Nick naulty.
Uh,
Tom fucking cruise.
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
Awesome.
That must've been a party.
He played that crazy executive guy.
Oh,
fun filming that movie.
Oh fuck.
Yeah.
That must've been a wild time.
That's a classic.
That's an all time classic.
Not Time.
Many of them,
man.
Not that many.
All time classes.
I liked the commercials at the beginning,
like whatever that is.
[inaudible] the booty.
A drink or Rick Swartz.
Come on,
there's going to do the podcast again.
I say I want to do it.
He did a movie and it bombed so bad.
He went to Hawaii for two months.
He just said,
I can't take it.
He goes,
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing.
He went to Hawaii for two months.
He did a movie that got a zero on rotten tomatoes.
Did it get released nationally or what was the movie?
Uh,
Bucky,
the porn star where he played,
uh Oh
that Joey was in that one.
Yeah.
Josie.
Send it bombed hard.
Yeah,
I heard of Israel.
That's weird to me cause I think even funny even it's so bad that at least that
there had to be one person that said,
yeah,
you know,
it's a dumb way.
It's an x war two movie.
It's what is what it is.
But
a lot of these movies,
man,
there's a lot of people fucking with it,
especially on a,
if you're a guy like Nick Swardson,
this is your first shot at making a big movie with your name on it.
That might've been a lot of cooks in the kitchen.
You know,
I told this story before I was on a movie once a Frank McCluskey Cei and I had
the scene that eventually got cut out of the whole movie.
But I watched this funny dude get all these different line readings from all
these executives.
They're all telling them how to do it and they completely ruined the movie.
I watched it happen.
I watched all these guys in suits,
literally tell this guy how to do his scene and that like,
this is what I want you to,
I want you to come in.
Like they were,
they were telling,
they won't even do the director and the director couldn't do shit about it.
He was powerless and the whole thing became a mess,
but easily
could have happened to a movie and everyone just shits on it.
[inaudible] you know,
uh,
while we're on that subject really quick,
um,
I,
I did a short movie,
Super Low budget with,
with a Joey DHEAS and with [inaudible],
we're releasing it on my youtube channel tonight at midnight.
It's called return of the depth knuckle.
Um,
it's going to be interesting to see.
Do doesn't even look real.
I saw the,
it doesn't look real.
Looks like your pumpkin people.
That's what I with dot.
Kates potato about that too.
It's actually,
we actually did,
whose idea was the movie?
Well,
it was,
it was like this.
It was supposed to be,
well this the,
there's other music.
Oh,
let's add another song in the background.
Brian.
Brian,
what do you doing,
Brian?
Positive Shit.
So he killed that song.
What the fuck can you play?
What are you playing?
I don't even know where it's coming from.
That was you serious.
You don't know where it's coming from.
Look at your browser.
Open your browser.
It's something's playing you freak.
What are you doing?
You ready to kill yourself?
Do you have something to tell me?
If that's the music you listening to,
will he leave?
Can imagine you listen to like burl Ives and shit.
Bam.
[inaudible] volume.
This is Flavio de Souza
got more a black belt cop killer.
I don't want you guys take any unnecessary risks out there.
He's already killed one.
[inaudible] the people just listen to audio.
Really ridiculous shit.
It looks,
most people listening,
this was just a lot of music is what it is.
If you go online,
you can see this clip on youtube,
but it's fair.
That was very honestly [inaudible] comments.
What would you think was awesome about it?
Uh,
cause I know Eddie,
you know,
so,
and I know
Joey and I think your fans and I think people that know you are gonna love it.
I at least that's what I would think because I think it looks fucking,
I want to say,
I'm sure you just never know.
I screened it in Saint Louis last Saturday.
I'd probably like 30,
like 10.
You have to be a,
you have to know the,
the,
the character [inaudible] he's actually a 10 out the lounge up playing Flavio
does is so it's like a,
it's fake within fake,
you know what I mean?
So we got like,
like we ended up in the same goddamn movie.
Fuck I got,
you know what I mean?
And in the movie I play a cop like a really cool,
like Vince Vaughn type cop going after his nap.
Alondra,
this,
this Brazilian steroid trafficker,
he's the son of an assay plantation owner,
dude in Joey killed it in the jellies in it to man.
He plays into the movement.
Funny.
Is it funny dude?
If you understand the characters,
everyone was dying.
Everyone thinks it's insane.
Pools.
Everyone.
Uh,
that was that at the,
at the screening in Saint Louis,
unless they lied to me,
people were laughing their asses off and said it was,
well,
there's always an audience.
I don't know.
I don't,
regular people might not get it.
They're probably like people that don't know,
like if you're not a hardcore MMA fan,
you probably ain't going to understand like the whole Brazilian hand apple think
is,
it's really,
it is like an inside joke.
I would love to see it to see if I understand it cause I don't know anything
that's going,
you wouldn't understand it.
You know,
I had a conversation with what I had to do some stuff today for the UFC and the
dude who I'm talking to is a friend of mine,
my friend John.
And uh,
he thought it was real.
He totally thought it was real.
I go,
no,
no.
I go,
this is my pet out though.
Yeah.
I go to a friend of mine,
I go,
he's a brown belt under Eddie.
He's a really good guy.
He's an actor and he's like,
no fucking way.
I go,
yeah.
He goes,
you mean their whole thing that James Brown that was fake?
I go,
yeah,
it was fake.
We were just fucking around.
It's like,
did you have a scrip?
No,
we just started.
We're just fucking around.
No,
man.
Everybody thinks that's real.
That I was a real guy that was like mad at me.
I will say this,
I haven't took acting lessons in like 15 years.
My acting's not going to be fucking Robert Dinair.
I was,
you know,
it's,
it's okay at best,
right.
But raison as [inaudible],
every scene,
every word that came out of his mouth,
the way we put this together is,
um,
Christo Garcia.
He came to me,
he's a guy,
he produces television shows on like cable and stuff and his,
he has asked where he's a karate guy and his aspirations where you need to be
this filmmaker making like big karate movies.
He came to my gym and said,
dude,
I want to put you in a movie.
I got a script and you're going to be a trainer.
Like a Mr Miyagi.
Dude.
I'm like,
I go,
man,
I'll act.
You know what I mean?
But I'm not going to audition for shit if people offer me,
like I was a number back down to,
I didn't like audition for that and I'm not gonna,
I'm not gonna,
I'm not taking acting that seriously.
But if someone comes to me and says,
I want to put you in a movie,
am I going to say no?
I said,
okay,
I'll do it.
We sat down,
he showed me some scripts,
he's got like three martial arts scripts.
I'm like,
okay.
He goes,
dude,
I'm going to put you in this one and I think you'd be great in this.
I go,
do you haven't even seen me act like,
are you sure I get it?
I sent him quad too funny.
He goes,
dude,
you could ask.
So anyways,
anyways,
I love the people make movies like that.
I didn't even,
I'd even,
so this is what happened.
So I told him,
I go,
I can totally just be in your movies and just read your lines and stuff like
that.
We could do that or you could let me,
you know,
bring in like my people,
cause I got some talented people around me and he goes,
he was like totally cool.
He goes,
yeah,
Woo Hoo.
He didn't know.
He didn't know Hassan.
And he didn't know Joey at all.
I sat them down and go watch these motherfuckers.
These guys are already hits.
People already love them.
They're already grand slam jewels.
Let's,
let's put them in.
Let's put them all in this shit and make this a comedy.
And he goes,
what?
I go,
I already got,
I already got the store cause I had the Joey karate story in my head,
I've been trying to put it together like the real,
like Joey karate as like,
you know,
I'm going to black belt.
Yeah,
yeah.
But yeah,
but he'd be like a mob guy.
My idea was he's a mob dude,
like a hit man who wants to get out of the mob and do MMA cause he's like this
big karate MMA fan.
Right.
And he wants to get out of them up.
So I had this idea and I,
and uh,
we were going to roll with it.
He wanted me,
he wanted to do it.
Oh,
for people that don't loge Brion pull up,
pull up Joey karate.
Gimme a Joey karate because he does one where he gets attacked and it is fucking
awesome.
Man.
Fights the dudes off,
come on his care whatever ways.
That's an amazing and Joey and basically he's not even acting like he grew up
doing karate.
And the crazy thing about Joey growing up doing karate in New York is that
Rustin's dad was his teacher.
Isn't that nuts?
You knew that,
right?
Yeah.
Okay.
Is that it's fucking crazy.
What are the fucking possible odds of all the teachers?
Yes.
Give me some volume people.
People watching this at home can see.
That's right.
Yeah.
We were watching Joe.
What's the name of this one?
Brian is the first joke.
Writing totally karate number one.
If he really knows karate,
real shit.
I'm serious.
He's the funniest guy that's ever walked the face of the earth.
No one's even close.
No one close to Joey is mad flavor.
Oh Dude.
This is a fucked always showing karate,
so you understand me here for the UFC minute,
people seem in the medical marijuana reports.
A lot of people seem in the sports reports,
but nobody really knows.
I'm a trained fucking assassin,
Cuban black belts.
I lost my rank on the fucking boat ride over,
came knocked McDonald's Greenberg and I'm fighting to get it back and then
stabbed me.
I take my shit back from the fucking jungle in China,
Hong Kong,
Olivia.
That's why training is fucking savages.
These little fucking guys flying through the air.
Just joke around.
He's going to give you the lock for UFC and it's all about fucking Brazil this
weekend.
You understand me,
my man,
and this is Silva gonna fuck people up this weekend in his name.
He went through kiss Leben.
He went through forest with a far as Griffin,
lumped them out.
Let me show you.
I'll put this motherfucker first off is and together with a clip.
That's the movie type Shit.
You understand that?
I started movies die.
I'm not really entirely over the Thai restaurant.
I'm fucking guy with the quench go home.
He used to the fucking head check.
I'm going to psychic Lisa Gentleman to some fucking Samurai.
Well some on bar with some fucking choke them out.
It's that simple.
And this is Sylvia,
the Samueli,
those traditional,
well that's it baby girl.
Forget UFC.
Catch me next week.
What?
All my other things.
I'm his family next week we're going to cover stretching and flying through the
fuck.
They're
fucking there.
Come on.
That was great.
And you could tell like that was his first one.
That was all gold.
But like now when he does them,
he's just so like conflict cause he was just getting into the UFC back then.
He wasn't into MMA for a while.
He was hanging out with us.
He hated it when we talked about the UFC.
But then when the ultimate fighter came out,
he was one of those guys that got hooked through the ultimate fighter and all of
a sudden he's a fanatic.
And that was the first one.
He,
he,
he'll admit he didn't have as much confidence picking back then cause he's new
to the sport.
But now when you watch them do the the 10th planet Kush is,
he's on fucking fire.
He knows MMA,
the keynote,
he knows,
he knows shit about MMA.
That I would never know like he knows when the next five you fcs are at and what
stadium,
what city?
He knows all that shit.
It's crazy.
I don't know when the fucking next UFC as there's like three a month.
Yeah.
Joey's a fan though.
Here.
They're going to be in Baltimore next week.
I'm like,
Oh shit.
Really?
He thinks that everything's a scam.
You know,
he thinks whenever there's an underdog,
if an underdog wins is like you'd never met a booklet with a part time job
and that's what he said during Cain Velasquez and junior dos Santos.
He said it and I got him on film at the show at the UFC goes and I just wanted
to get his prediction because we didn't do a 10th planet cush for that UFC and
he goes and he said just like that,
you never seen a bookie with a part time job.
Something's up right here.
Look for King of Alaska is the go down quick.
Could you call this Joey karate called it.
Could you imagine if it was a scam if we found that that fighters,
that fighters,
we're letting dudes knocked him out and shit like that cause they bet a fuck
load of money on them.
Is that possible?
Yeah.
I always think things like that.
And you don't think that part for doing,
sorry,
I would never suggest that anybody's ever done that.
But don't you think that if someone tried to do that,
I don't believe that Cain Velasquez did that.
I believe came Velasquez got hit with a fucking hard shot man.
I don't think anybody who gets hit by that,
that's just one of those things about the first few minutes of an MMA fight when
a guy has like full steam,
a hundred percent junior was just starting to settle in.
He just walloped him,
man.
He,
if he hits anybody with that shot,
you're,
you're fucked.
He clubbed him.
I was a shocker.
It was a shocker.
It was brilliant.
I thought it would take a lot more to take king of Alaska's not,
I mean he got hit in that sweet spot right on the top of the side of the head.
Everybody goes down,
junior can fucking punch man.
He punches hard.
And you know when you see the impact,
you know where it actually landed.
It actually landed bone to bone.
Yep.
It didn't land with the uh,
the,
the actual padding and the glove.
Yeah.
He gave him a super negi Exupery actually.
Well yeah,
it's amazing that he didn't break his hand,
you know,
because I,
I guess that can function as a knuckle,
but God,
it can't be as hard as the top Nakil and I mean he blasted them.
Man.
That was a crazy punch.
It's crazy.
So here's a rate overall,
what do you think,
what should the bottom line as far as how that,
uh,
the opening show with Fox went down,
you think?
You think?
Uh,
it was,
cause it was good too.
It was like,
look,
now you could build this guys like Mike Tyson.
Yeah.
Goes out there and Mike Tyson's dudes,
it wasn't bad for Mike Tyson was it?
It's never bad when a guy can stop a guy that quick.
I don't think it's ever bad.
I'm in a,
it's,
it wasn't the best demonstration of mixed martial arts in the sense that it
didn't go back and forth.
You didn't see like a long fight where the momentum changed hands in Kendo and
show gun shit.
But I think other than that,
it was a great result.
I mean it was,
it was stunning,
you know,
was,
it was,
it was decisive.
You know,
junior dropped him,
jumped all over him,
bad,
battered,
dumb.
There was no doubt about it was a perfect stoppage.
See,
I think that's good.
A perfect stop.
Which is good.
I know.
I think watching a guy take a guy out legit in 64 seconds and especially when
you're taking the guy out like Cain Velasquez,
holy shit man.
That's God damn.
That's impressive.
Well,
when you look at what we learned from the fight,
like you said,
we learned that Holy Shit,
junior dos Santos is like the Mike Tyson of and the main,
now he's knocking dudes a big block,
heads out in one punch.
Yet Sarah,
he's got really good timing.
I mean,
he doesn't catch everybody in every fight,
you know,
like,
and then some dudes he couldn't put away like he couldn't play it put away Roy
Nelson.
Roy Nelson is a monster man.
Boy Nelson,
God damn,
that guy,
he lost weight finally.
Holy Shit.
He's going to lose more to Holy Shit.
He knows man looked.
He's fucking good dude.
Roy Roy Nelson actually said to me in the cage after the fight,
like,
you're always calling me fat.
I'm like,
you know,
I got stuck there.
I'm like,
I don't want to say I didn't want to insult him,
but I said,
but it's because you're fat.
And,
and he calls himself out.
He comes out to that Michael Jackson fats.
I don't say it because I don't like them.
I love that guy.
I think he's talented as fuck.
I think it's amazing that he's able to do what he can do and be in the kind of
physical condition that he's in.
I mean,
carrying around that extra weight.
I know that he's strong and he's got good cardio.
He's got good endurance for a big guy that can't be helping.
I'm just no way that helps them.
I go down to one 70 can you imagine?
You would ever know.
I think he can ever know.
I think he'd go to oh five though.
I think he go raid five and 300 yeah,
but I think he's a bigger guy.
Big countries.
A thick fucking guy.
You in his head,
his bands.
One of the reasons why I take a shot so well,
he's so sturdy.
You know I don't,
I don't see that guy going below two oh five I think even two oh five is going
to be a struggle for them.
Even if you got down to a low body fat.
He's a thick fucking dude.
You know God damn that motherfucker can punch for a Jujitsu guy.
Big countries got a serious right hand.
The one he put Brendan Schaub out with Bob Plan.
There's a lot of hardcore Roy Nelson fans that have always stuck up for his
fatness and now they're all pissed off.
You know?
I liked it when he was fat.
There's gotta be,
yeah,
a lot of fat guys do,
man.
I have fat friends that love it.
When Roy blast somebody out now they're like shit or hero.
He sold out.
He wants to beat the best guys.
He could be like a,
you know,
no offense,
but he could be like a butter bean of MMA,
you know?
Or he could really go for it.
You know,
Roy Nelson Dude has a chance against a lot of fucking people,
man and Roy Nelson,
if he loses weight,
has a chance of,
again,
the more way he loses,
the better condition he gets,
the more people he's going to be able to beat.
That guy is a beast,
man.
You see what he did?
He Cro cop once he got his back.
Yup.
He's a fucking beast and he took some shots in that fight.
Cro.
Cop hit him with some bombs.
Man,
there's an animated Gif of Cro cop having him up against the fence and he's
covering up and rolling with punches and Cro.
Cop is just blasted him.
Do just put full blast cause he knows that Roy is not falling back and Roy just
ate at all.
He didn't say it at all.
I mean he can fucking take it man.
I've known him tough as shit.
I've known him for a long ass time and I've always known him as a Jujitsu guy.
So him becoming this badass striker,
crazy,
shocking.
I've known him for a long time.
He's always been really good with Jujitsu.
I think he's just a badass period,
you know.
I mean he might have this,
you know,
overweight body,
but that dude is underneath all that shit.
He's uh,
he's like,
you know,
he's like a super athlete that has like a disadvantage,
like a super athlete that wears a weight vest when he goes into a fight.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
bad ass.
He would be at two oh five.
Holy Shit.
Yup.
And now what's up with that?
What was your thoughts on the Henderson Shogun fight?
There was the greatest fight in the history of,
of fight.
The greatest.
Yeah,
I think it was the greatest fight of all time.
I do.
Yeah.
And it wasn't because both guys were in the best shape they could possibly be
in.
And it wasn't because,
you know,
it wasn't because they were at the top of their game.
It was because it was so fucking real.
It went back and forth in Shogun came so close to getting stopped and Dan
Henderson,
God damn,
can he punch hard?
He broke shoguns whole face,
dude.
Sjogren's,
whole faces,
fuck he might have to get is,
you know,
face put back together again.
You know,
it's got like orbital fractures and cheek fractures and shit and he got a drew
that and then wind up taking Anderson down.
I mean dude,
it was crazy.
I mean it the best display of defense versus offense or two guys that you know
in the putting on like a,
you know,
a GSP,
Anderson Silva type performance.
But what it was was fucking,
as far as like matchups,
you couldn't get a tighter matchup.
It,
they were so close,
it ended just like rocky one.
Yeah.
You know,
a rocky.
Yeah.
Basically beat his ass.
And Apollo creed got saved by the ballot.
Like Apollo thought,
you know,
rocky one,
but you know,
he wouldn't say it.
He won't admit it.
Well,
Dana said that he thought that it was a draw.
I honestly haven't watched it.
Again,
like if you,
if there's a thing about when you're doing commentary,
what I'm trying to do is I'm trying to be entertaining.
I'm going to try and explain what's happening and you're not looking at it as
like very precisely and cleanly as if you writing down things only.
Like,
remember when you used to judge,
he,
Eddie had a system that was pretty smart.
He wrote,
he broke down a piece of paper and then he would,
you know,
have one guy's name on one side,
one guy's name on another side,
and then you'd break it down by strikes,
take downs.
You had like all these different categories and you would check off each
category.
Um,
yeah,
I'd have like a short hand method for different flurries and different punches.
So that man,
you forget by the end of the round,
you will forget,
you will look back on,
I'm like okay.
In the beginning of the round he had to take down.
That's right.
You forget.
So especially if something really big happens,
you know,
and then you get locked onto that for a second.
Yeah.
You can forget what happened in the beginning of that round.
So,
and then you put it all together and when it's close,
I just look at,
damn,
okay.
I have,
he had two big right hands.
He had a five leg kicks.
He had to take down an avenue some time to think about it.
I go,
ah,
and you could,
instead of thinking about it in your head and going back and forth,
you actually see what happened.
And there's so many times where it's a 10,
nine round where they just fucking flip a coin man.
It's like,
you know who the hell knows?
You know,
there's some 10,
nine rounds.
There really should be draws.
You know,
it's,
there's,
there's gotta be a difference between,
you know,
one of those rounds where nothing really happened,
but dude landed three leg kicks and the other dude landed a good left hook to
the body and that's it.
That,
that's a ten nine round.
And then the last round of Henderson Shogun is a ten nine round to like there's,
there's,
they got to give more,
10 eights they got to give more.
10 10 they got John and,
and I hear the commission is telling these judges to not give 10 tens and not
give ten eight that's ridiculous.
Yeah.
I don't think,
I think people don't want,
they don't want to see draws.
They want to see a clear decisive decision.
But sometimes the correct answer is it's a draw,
you know?
And you can't make a winner in let you know if you don't want to,
you shouldn't,
you shouldn't.
As a judge,
you know,
I hope no commissions actually encourage them to do that because that seems like
they're meddling with the results.
That's what I read on the underground.
I might not be right.
We should,
we should be careful.
Before.
So something like that.
Yeah,
that's just a rumor that,
that the commission is telling the judges.
I mean,
I think that's a real,
I hope that's not true.
That does.
It seems like they're tampering with results.
You know,
the saying that you have to pick a winner on one side or the other.
There are times where you shouldn't to pick a winner.
You know,
the unfortunate,
yeah.
But there are fights that are draws,
man.
There,
there are fights that are absolutely draws like the,
um,
a lot of people knew a lot of people.
The Frankie Edgar Gray Maynard,
the second fight,
you know the crazy one.
Yeah.
The last one was crazy too.
The third one was pretty fucking crazy too.
But the second one,
um,
I mean that is,
that's the proudest close to a draws you can get.
Right.
Don't you think?
You don't want to have to see it again?
I don't remember.
I'd have to see it again too.
But I remember thinking like back and forth and what a first round for gray
Maynard and you know,
I mean Frankie Edgar was as that any three out of five judges could have easily
stopped that fight.
You know,
if there are trigger happy,
if they'll stop fights early eight either.
Either one of those knocked out,
there's a few knockdowns or he went down where a care,
a judge who's like ultra careful would have stopped it or referee shogun could
easily,
it felt like it was,
it should have been stopped.
But when you,
you can't really,
you can't really say that because the bite wasn't stopped and it was let go and
Shogun did come back.
So that was great refereeing by Josh Rosenthal.
He to me,
Josh and her,
they're just the best,
the best.
They don't stop shit too early.
Do Nothing.
Pisses me off more than,
you know,
as far as a rough goes is stopping and goddamn fight to her.
I shit.
Yeah,
let's see.
A decisive,
well,
I said down about a Kung Lee and Vandelay Silva.
I said,
I don't agree with that stoppage because Kang was to hold onto a single and
Vandelay hit him with a couple of Hammerfest.
But then,
you know,
when Ken got up,
he didn't seem to complain and his nose was smashed,
you know,
and maybe the referee being closer to the action,
I had a better idea of that hung was,
he was probably close to stopping in any way.
I thought the same button,
but I saw the Hammerfest and I was like,
that's not enough man.
You,
you know,
it's like you guys still trying cause look,
shogun came back,
you know,
and he was still trying.
I like the shot.
Yeah.
Brock cat five fights that could have easily been stopped.
Just,
you know,
I like to see guys come back.
It's,
it's fun.
I don't mean,
you know,
to be disrespectful to a referee and I to,
when I say they shouldn't stop it,
it's just,
it's just an opinion thing,
you know?
You don't have to agree with it,
but I think you've got to give guys the opportunity to win.
You've got to give guys an opportunity if he's still fighting,
you know,
he wasn't covering up in a ball in the fetal position,
Eaton shots,
he was grabbing his leg and he's very likely done.
Very likely would have just taken even more unnecessary punishment.
But I think you got to give him a chance.
You know,
dudes can pull shit off,
man.
Dudes,
you know,
and Connolly's a bad motherfucker.
I'm not saying that he would have pulled it off,
but I ended up bad stoppage.
It ain't a bad stoppage.
He never appeared to me as well.
Right.
When he stopped it,
I'm like,
aw man,
that was too quick.
But he never,
he didn't get up on his feet for awhile.
I stayed on his knees.
It was a good stop.
It was a good stoppage.
But it was his,
it
was like a judgment call that he made over,
you know,
Kung trying,
I think you're done.
And he was right.
He was right.
And you know,
maybe he would have been able to pull something off,
but most likely not,
most likely he would've just taken more shots.
And you know,
Vandelay Silva was like vintage Vandelay Silva in that fight.
Dude,
when he got the,
the clinician was delivering those knees.
Damn.
I was like,
I remembered how awesome he was with knees when they in the rampage fights and
pride.
He's one of the best man when he gets that plum clinch on your neck.
Oh my God.
He puts so much into those knees.
I'd like,
I hadn't seen a guy knee somebody like Vandelay did in a long time.
Yeah.
It was like the last one was um,
who the fuck kill a bee?
Ben Saunders.
Yeah.
Member he fought some dude and gave him a vicious barrage of needs.
Like that dude was that,
I don't remember the Duty Fahd Hawaiian gentlemen,
I believe.
Killaby Ben Saunders.
He's got some crazy rubber guard variation shit going on,
right?
Yeah.
And some,
some other technique.
We had his arm through it actually seeing Tiago Tavarez d play rubber guard in
that way.
Yeah.
But not successfully.
But he tried it a few times in the MC,
uh,
but a killer v Ben Saunders,
he was able to,
uh,
use that control very effectively against a high level Jujitsu guy,
a black belt.
I think he was a world champion as well and totally stuffed on many.
He did it over and over and over again throughout the fight.
So that I never play that style of rubber guard.
But,
um,
uh,
it's,
I mean eventually I'll,
I'll,
uh,
dive into it.
It just feels kind of uncomfortable for me right now,
but it's,
uh,
it's,
it's looked awesome on the hand.
Ben Always told me,
he said,
dude,
I can't wait for you to see my rubber guard,
man.
I got to kill the rubber guard.
He's been saying that for a couple of years.
I just haven't seen it.
He hasn't really been in a position
that's probably the number one hole.
If you had to pick like what's the most common whole the fighters have in their
game in MMA?
It's a guard,
right?
Wouldn't you say?
Yes,
absolutely.
Cause there's some dudes,
there's a few dudes that,
you know,
you go on the ground with them and like,
like a Vinnie Magallanes,
you go on the ground,
Vinny Magalhaes you get in his guard,
you're very likely to get fucked up.
Yeah.
He's at least going to make it so you can dangerous.
The Rubber Guard is,
is Ma,
you know,
it's,
it's defensive.
Uh,
powers are just,
I mean you can't,
if you,
if you're breaking your opponent down and you haven't been in Michigan troller
and visible color,
it's impossible for him to hurt you.
Yeah.
You're fully clenched,
you know,
and you know,
you wear them out,
try trying to get out of it.
Very hard to get out.
There's a lot of effort and it's,
it's really comes down to,
you know,
MMA fighters have so much to do that don't have time to develop some new game.
And that crazy.
There's just so much to do because you got to do your kickboxing,
you got to do your wrestling,
and then you've got to do your Jujitsu and then you've got to run and then you
got to do your strength.
And conditioning.
There's so much to do.
The only way you're going to get better at anything,
anything in life is by drilling,
in putting numbers in massive numbers,
drill,
and you don't,
there's just,
there's just no time to drill new positions.
When you're an MMA fighter,
he got so much to do.
You know what happens is in striking,
that's all they do is drill because you can't really spar 100% all the time.
So if you want to work on,
you're striking,
you're going to be working on drills because you can't just go knocking out
your,
your training partners.
So you're forced to draw the time.
So you see these guys that are wrestlers them and within three years they're
striking is tremendous.
I mean,
Frankie Edgar's like a professional kickboxer you're seeing these guy Dominick
Cruz because in,
when they're working on the striking,
they have to work on their drills.
That's all there is.
When Jujitsu,
they look at a different,
at most MMA fighters will,
will,
uh,
they'll,
they'll just roll and work on their Jujitsu.
Maybe it's more fun.
Yeah,
they'll just roll and cause you invite the role for people.
No,
mean spar,
spar,
it's,
it's so Jujitsu's the only sport that you could spar a hundred percent and,
and,
and no one gets hurt really.
I mean,
and you're practicing tapping your opponent out 100%.
You can act,
you can't do that with kickboxing.
You just can't.
So what ends up happening in Jujitsu,
there's not that much drilling.
There's not that much working on spending time working on new techniques.
It's just sparring with punches and sparring is very important and very,
very,
you got to do that.
But you also to add weapons to your Jujitsu,
to just pile them on,
add different submissions.
You have to set time aside to just drill,
put the numbers in to these submission holds that you want to add to your game.
If you're not a,
um,
a guillotine master,
it's not because the guillotine doesn't work.
There's plenty of people out there that are proven the guilt and you get really
good at it.
Man.
It's a dangerous weapon.
If you're drilling teen isn't good.
You need to put,
you need a practice that over and over and over again and no one does.
There's just,
when in MMA there's just not enough time to set 20 minutes aside every other day
to work on a new submission holds into to sharpen him up,
you know?
So that's really the problem is they're just not enough time to practice new
move.
Yeah,
it's often for a fighter it's maybe sometimes the best thing is to come to MMA
with is one thing where you're super awesome at it,
whether it's judo or kickboxing,
one thing that you're already awesome and then sort of incorporate all the other
stuff into it,
you know,
because it seems like it's real hard for a guy to be learning everything and be
awesome at anything.
It's real hard.
It's real hard to,
you know,
it's like to reach a Damien Maia Jujitsu level when Damien Maia was just pure
Jujitsu,
you know,
to reach that level.
It's so hard to be doing that while you're trying to be a great kickboxer.
And also trying to be a great wrestler was Damien is just
concentrate only on positions and submissions and bang,
Bang,
Bang.
He's going through numbers on you and you,
you you're adding in all this other stuff and when you add in all of this stuff,
you just don't have the time to put it in the kind of focus that he has.
It's almost like you're better off coming in
in with one specialty.
You know,
generally wrestling is probably the best,
although a lot of other sports do translate beautifully into MMA grappling.
Especially like if you played soccer your whole life,
it man,
you're,
you can learn Jujitsu really quick and,
and excel really quick in the same thing with striking.
If you play football your whole life,
you're used to beat your explosiveness is that are,
you know,
at at the highest levels and Capoeira and break dancing.
All that stuff translates cause in break dancing,
the kind of stuff they're doing nowadays,
it's just the amount of balance needed to pull these moves off off the chart.
It's way more balanced required than wrestling and wrestling.
You need a lot of balance,
but in breakdancing you got to spin and flip and land on one had all this
balance.
So yeah,
when they need to teach them Jujitsu,
it's,
they're like all I gotta do to stay on top and not get swept.
Oh my God,
this is easy.
It's easy season balance.
Bill Cooper is a,
is a prime example of that.
Bill Cooper is one of the greatest American Jujitsu players and he's been a
break dancers whole life.
And you know,
it wasn't a shocker.
Well it,
you know,
I didn't find out to recently,
but it's no surprise that he went out and just dominated the American scene in
Jujitsu and he's doing MMA now too.
And um,
uh,
there's a Jujitsu guy named Cabrina who did cop a wearer,
which is like,
you know,
African or a Brazilian like dancing,
fighting type thing.
And they do all these crazy flips his,
and he did cover where his whole life,
he started Jujitsu in his early twenties and now he's amazing.
He's one of the best Jujitsu guys on,
on the planet at his weight.
Um,
and he'll tell you that it's from the Capoeira,
like all that Bouncy,
such an amazing athlete,
that Jujitsu Jujitsu's easy to them.
You know,
it totally makes sense.
I would think that anybody who does gymnastics or yes,
yes.
That translate.
Yes,
for sure.
Totally translate.
Yeah.
Yeah,
for sure.
Like you know,
I have a son coming and he'll be coming in March.
I'm a,
I'm a get him into all that stuff.
I'm going to try to get him into break dancing,
gymnastics,
wrestling for sure.
The other thing is,
uh,
when you,
you can develop really high level striking and then develop takedowns that's the
other terrifying fighter.
Like the guys like Anderson,
you know,
like you should know Cami fight.
Yeah.
Cause he had some sick take down defense.
Yup.
And then you're forced to stand up with him and that's a goddamn disaster.
Yeah.
You know,
that's that,
that's the other style and the only way you can get to be as good as Anderson is
it striking is I believe you have to focus purely on striking for a long time.
Yeah.
You know,
an Anderson was,
you know,
pretty much a Moy Thai initially.
You know,
until I think it was,
I think it was really like the Nogueira brothers before he really put his ground
game together.
Right.
That's after,
I mean he had to ground a little bit of a ground game for shoot box,
but I see a lot of guys out there.
You see it in their career early there were easy to take down.
Then they'd gotten a little harder.
Now they're almost impossible to take down.
You see the progression.
You see the progression of the striking.
Yeah.
You know,
you see them getting a lot better.
I mean quick because all they do is drill.
I can wrestling.
Those are just drills.
Wrestling is just mostly drills,
you know,
he imagine how,
how long it would take to get good at throwing combinations.
If you never drilled in you all you did with spar,
like you would never develop any kind of combos.
You never,
it would be impossible all you did flow.
Yeah.
We'll just be really basic stuff.
They want to be crisp.
The technique would be terrible.
If you think of like a one,
two left hook to the body that you practice over and over on the back of that,
ma'am,
how are you ever going to pull that off list randomly in real life?
You know,
you would,
you would even think like that.
Yeah.
You'd have to learn it first learner first,
develop the movement and then start doing it.
It's the beauty of Jujitsu.
Jujitsu is so amazing and so awesome because you can spar 100% and no one gets
hurt and you're actually working on killing techniques and bone breaking
techniques.
It's,
it's like paintball for hand to hand combat.
It's so much fun.
You can actually spar.
You can't do that with any other,
uh,
as a combat sport that it's so cool and so awesome that people don't drill as
much as they should.
Especially in MMA especially.
You don't,
you don't see fighters like,
oh,
early in his career he was going at these two submissions and then in the middle
of his career he added these two and then towards the end he started hitting
these in these that you never see that you never see them.
The only,
the only one guy that I did see evolve and add different submissions is
Nogueira.
No,
in the beginning was the triangle king earliness careers.
Like,
man,
this big dude has a great guard.
He's triangling everybody.
Then you didn't see triangles for while and then he started Anaconda choking
people,
you know,
and throw on some gear teens.
So you saw that,
oh damn,
he's getting good at Anaconda chunks now you see that because he had some of the
dopest Anaconda chokes and MMA that takes,
he's tiring.
That takes us right to Bob Sapp.
Nogueira how perfect was that?
You got that to you up?
Listen,
we're going to play this fight.
We were,
Eddie and I are talking about all time great fights and we,
we,
we uh,
played a Kimbo slice versus tank Abbott fight on my phone.
We weren't sure if they fought and we played it on my phone,
uh,
outside of legends in Hollywood where we trained and uh,
we will,
we were just doing commentary why it was going on and we were like,
damn,
you know,
this is a fight that we forgot even happened.
You know,
it's cool to watch like an old fight.
So we're going to watch,
uh,
we haven't seen it.
I haven't seen in a long time.
We're going to do our best impression [inaudible] and butthead,
watching a fly conic fight in MMA.
This is one of the most iconic fights of all time.
Minotauro Nogueira versus Bob Sapp.
Bob Sab was the biggest human being to ever walk the face of the earth.
He doesn't even look real in this video.
It's like 350 pounds.
All muscle,
all muscles fighting,
the Jujitsu God Noguera who's only about to hear about two 20 and right now he
gets piled,
drived on his head first move and this big giant guys on top of him punching him
over and over and over again.
And he's picking them up again,
trying to slam him down.
And no,
Gerome literally is maybe 150 pounds lighter than this dude.
I'll never forget,
this is one of those fights were actually,
remember what I was thinking?
I remember what I was saying while I was watching it.
We're watching it at Larry's house and I kept going at this point,
once he started getting pile driven,
I kept going.
We were so,
we were all just yelling and screaming during all of this and I kept thinking,
I kept saying he's,
he's just too big.
He's too big.
There's no way he's going to pull this off.
He's just way too fucking big.
It looks like a molestation.
Oh,
the member where the lights went out,
the lights from out in the middle of the fight.
They kept fighting to bookies.
Did that.
Yeah.
Cut The lights to light.
That's hilarious.
And so Minataro at the time,
uh,
wasn't even the heavyweight champion yet,
right?
Who was just coming up?
I don't remember that.
I don't remember if he was the chair and burnout.
I remember either.
But Minataro had a,
a wicked triangle.
He triangled everybody triangle Mark Coleman has guard was nasty back in the
day.
He was like the first real heavyweight submission bad-ass off his back.
He was the first guy to just put people to sleep.
He was my hero.
I'm like,
finally we have a a big Jujitsu guy who can finish people off as back.
We didn't have that.
That's so rare.
There was no other Brazilian elders.
All the legends that none of them were known for finishing people off their back
in MMA,
in Jujitsu tournaments.
Then we felt finishing off their back all the time sweeping but an MMA.
They weren't doing it and Nogueira was the first one to consistently Finnish
people off his back and now he's leg kicking him now.
They stood up and he shoots on him.
I mean he is literally 150 pounds bigger.
Bob Sapp is so big,
it doesn't even look real man.
He doesn't look anything like this,
anything.
I had no hope at this point.
I go,
he's done.
He's about to get just smashed.
I thought it was over.
So now Bob Sapp is trying to get know Garrett and a good team from half guard,
but he doesn't know what he's doing and he's playing around in minute Taros
guard and he's getting tired.
Now the thing about a guy that big,
there's no way his heart is proportionate to his body.
His heart is like having a four cylinder engine,
you know,
trying to push a semi,
you know there's too much mass,
you know,
and he's getting crushed here.
He's getting stomped on.
Minataro is on the bottom.
They're just saying no hope at this point.
Like what is it going to be able to do?
He hasn't been able to get close to doing anything.
He can't even wrap his legs around his shoulders and Bob Sapp is so fucking
strong.
He landed a one two.
I'm going to,
Tara was trying to box with him now.
No Bob Sapp throat.
Those are real slow kick now.
Mandatorial tees off with the combination and Bob Sapp pushes him.
Bob Sapp is so fucking big man.
God Damn,
he looks fake.
Two minutes Horrow was throwing,
I forgot about that.
He was thrown down.
He said,
fuck it.
I'm going to stand with this dude and just give it all I have.
That's what he did.
He just,
he just going for it right here,
man.
The size of Bob Sapp,
he looks fake man
and him and Minotauro Boxing.
Now football players aren't even that big.
Three films.
Muscle.
That's a cartoon man.
He really does look like a character in a,
in a,
in an animated TV show.
He's trying to take town bombs that,
that's hilarious.
Editorials trying to take him down,
but you can get out.
But he sits out.
Look at that.
Oh,
that one.
Oh my goodness.
And now I'm going to Charles on top and now he gets right to side control.
And this was that.
Everybody was going crazy.
Crazy.
We were screaming.
There's amazing.
He finally got on top of them.
This is the only hope here is his only hope.
And Bob Sapp turns over and puts me in a Toro and his guard Minataro oh,
he's throwing some crazy up kicks now man.
The bill passes.
God again.
It looked like he landed a couple of those 10.
Yeah.
It looked like he dead.
Minataro the other thing about Minataro was Goddamn,
he can take it.
He could take it better than anybody,
man.
Yeah.
Fay door pounded on him for that.
Take it too.
Especially earlier in his career.
Like these days,
you know?
Yeah.
These days when he was young.
Did we ever go nuts right here?
Yeah,
go nuts.
Like is he going to be able to pull this off?
He's got to do it here.
Like he had to do it here.
He knew it.
He knew this is it.
Oh,
what happened?
The referee is separate in the action right now.
Bob Saps got a little cut to cut to
some editorial,
gets a stand up and relax while they,
in Japan,
if you have a cut,
they stopped the action almost immediately and the doctors actually stopped the
bleeding.
The doctor's ringside actually like we'll stop the bleeding and put towels on it
and wait and then,
then they determine whether or not the guy can go back in.
So for a fight or sometimes you know,
it gives them a nice break.
Okay.
In America,
they don't do this.
Now.
All right that no,
the doctors don't,
the doctors aren't coming in and taking a look at a cut and stop the bleeding.
If doctors don't put like coagulants on it.
Right,
don't they?
I mean,
that's good question,
right?
I think so.
I mean,
do they put coagulants on it and pride and they put them in the same,
did they put Vaseline on them or are they just wipe it off
so they put them back in the same spot where I'm in a tar was wasn't side
control.
Google Middle Charles
got a nice head and arm right here.
Bob Sab was exhausted by this point.
He's just,
it's so crazy.
How tired gets
he reverses and Bob Cyber Versus,
Oh man,
look at that into side control.
Wow.
That was awesome.
I looked over at this point.
It's like,
okay.
That was his chance.
He just blew it to just blew it.
Now to over.
This is an all time classic fight.
Bob Stops hitting them with some hammer fists.
Bob Sapp Sky's back.
Oh my goodness.
Bob says trying to choke him.
Oh my God.
He Hammerfest some.
Oh.
Oh,
he's getting beat.
Bob.
Bob Sapp is gigantic.
My God,
he's struck.
Oh Shit.
Oh my God,
Dude.
He's like a fucking video game character.
Look at him back then.
Look at this.
He's running and trying to stomp on them.
Pride at some crazy rules,
man.
You were allowed to just jump on.
Dudes
jump out of their head bright at some nutty rules,
man,
and now,
right now he's on side control.
He's Bob Saps on top of them and Minataro again,
150 pounds fucking lighter than him and this the biggest human ever is
underneath them and he's still hip escaping.
He's hip escaping right now and Bob's have punches him in the head and he gets
to half guard.
I don't remember how he gets out of this
is getting blasted.
Oh my God.
Bob Sat SAP just hit him with two haymakers.
Jesus,
you look at his arms.
How much bust those punches hurt,
man.
Oh my God.
He dropped some hammer fist on his chest.
This point,
Bob Sapp seem unstar he goes for the arm bar here.
No,
he went in front the triangle.
Wow.
You used to go for risk control triangle,
but he can't control that guy's risks.
There's no way he could put a triangle on on those shoulders.
There's no way it can fit.
Right.
Impossible,
really.
Right.
No Way.
Look at those shoulders here.
Crazy.
He's so big.
It's crazy how he just faded into obscurity.
Who I don't even think he'd be.
He'd be,
I don't think he could keep up this level of supplementation for very long.
He did great.
And K one for a second there.
Yeah,
he did.
He beat her Nesto who's twice bro.
Oh,
he's down again.
Yo.
He stopped Ernesto hoost think about that shit.
And that's the WHO's one of the greatest kick boxers ever.
And Bob Sapp just kind of beast fucked him.
You know?
What are the rumors that that was fixed?
I don't know.
I didn't,
I didn't hear that rumor.
If that is,
if they did an amazing job and making it look real.
I've seen some fights that are for sure fixed.
Oh yeah.
Mark Coleman Takata are,
ya'll didn't want to say that,
but oh,
nice.
Right hand.
And the throwing down.
This is so crazy.
It just does,
does not look like it should be happening.
That a guy that big should be fighting against a guy that much smaller than
them.
This is the cool thing about pride though.
They would put on these freak show fights like this and they would,
you know,
it would be really interesting to see like you remember when fade or Fada that
huge dude.
What the Hell's his name?
Hung Man.
Troy.
Yup.
Remember that?
Oh my God.
Oh,
he's going to triangle triangle.
No Way.
He's going to pick his ass up and slap.
The guy picked him up and slammed him.
He was ferocious in this buy box.
Oh my God.
He was,
he's yelling at him and I'm like,
Nick Diaz,
this is when Bob Sapp was the shit man.
This is before Bob Sapp and you know,
got his eye socket broken by Cro cop and you know,
back then it was,
he was looking at crush everybody,
man.
Everybody was scared of Bob Sapp Shit.
Oh Dude.
Bob Sapp just punched him with a serious fucking right hand and now I'm going to
Tara.
I was really trying to get them down and if he gets him down then Bob Sapp is
fucked.
Nope.
Linda Tyler.
I was still in the bottom middle tars bleeding now is checking his face.
The big ass cut on his cheek.
Bob Sam was over him.
Hold on.
God Damn.
I bet he is.
It doesn't look real right.
He really doesn't look like a human being.
He looks like an animated character in a hobbit movie and now admitted Tara is
going for a leg lock here.
Tara is going for a leg lock here.
That's a good idea against big guys because generally they're not very good at
defending leg locks.
Mineral wool man gets everybody where he'll hugs and Minataro is now on his back
and Bob Saps on top of him and I was trying to hold on to a wrist.
He's got to rests here.
Oh,
what the fuck?
Why?
We'll go to part two.
There must be a part two.
Yeah
Dude,
the tension,
it's killing me.
That's an all time classic.
An all time classic for people who don't know.
That was like a,
it was almost like,
it had always been the question like how big could a guy being your Jujitsu
still works?
You know,
there's always those questions and some guys would say,
no,
he's too big.
You can't even use Jujitsu on them.
You can't use it.
He can't cancel minimum.
And that was,
uh,
you know,
a lot of people were thinking about pop SAP.
Like,
man,
how would you submit this guy?
Look at the size.
Oh,
but look at him.
Breathe man.
He's hyperventilating,
right?
Yeah.
He was panicking.
He needs to learn some of that.
Steve Maxwell breathing puff,
puff,
got to control your breath son.
And now they're checking,
um,
Mataros face cause he's got a cut and the Japanese shows the doctors would
actually stop the bleeding like this.
Another checking his eyes too to make sure he could still see.
Yeah,
they put some coagulant on it,
it looks like.
Yeah.
Minataro I thought he'd,
uh,
I forgot it took so much damage.
Did you remember?
He took so much damage this I remembered it as being a shorter fight.
Yeah,
me too.
Me Too.
Yeah,
I didn't,
he was getting his ass kicked like several times in the fight.
Well,
it's also one of the things that was kind of wild about pride was that 10 minute
first round,
that 10 minutes.
First round was a mother fucker man.
10 minutes.
It's crazy.
10 minutes is nuts.
And what else?
Pride did one other thing,
pride did that I really like is that they judged the fight as a whole.
So the last part of the fight was like very important.
Who was waiting at the end was very important.
Like what?
How did it turn out?
Well,
if it turns out at the end,
you're kicking that person's ass.
Really.
If you know,
if you walked up on a street fight and at the end of it the guy was on top and
punching the guy in the face,
that guy's the winter,
you know?
And he's getting his ass kicked again.
Who's this tall,
big hammer fisted by this enormous human being.
Oh,
he's getting killed.
You got to see this folks,
even if you're not a Jujitsu or an MMA fan,
just see this for the human spectacle of it cause it's so ridiculous.
The round ended,
I didn't even know the round ended.
Yeah,
so this is a second round.
Yep.
Wow.
It ends early in the second round and he goes back and look at that.
He's with Mario.
Fucking scary dude.
This is classic stuff.
That was his new boy.
He was bringing up,
God damn.
Okay,
hold on.
He got dropped on his head,
dude.
Remember when Gilbert Ivo got knocked out but Gilbert have all knocked out?
Gary Goodrich.
Yes.
Laid him out with that head kick,
laid them out.
He was asleep for like five minutes when he woke up.
This is an I worked at PRI.
When he woke up,
he,
this is what he told me.
He thought because he's from,
he's from Canada.
He thought when he was standing there with all the people on the music,
he thought he was at a rave in Toronto for an hour.
He thought he was at a reign and his sister,
which was,
who is Gary as sisters?
Always with them.
I got a spider.
He thought that was just some chick that he picked up at a rave in Toronto for
an hour.
He didn't even know it was the sister note.
He didn't know he was in Japan.
Oh Man.
He thought he was just fucked up on drugs.
That was gone.
Oh my God.
That's another classic bike.
That lots.
Here we go.
Round two.
This is the replay.
Oh Shit.
Okay.
Oh there's a pile drive.
Bam got hurt his neck and it bothered him for years.
Yeah.
So what I heard,
did he ever get it fixed?
Ah,
that's a good question.
I think so.
This fight might've ruined him.
Right
man.
You know,
who knows how good he could have been if he didn't take the donkey Kong shots.
He connected five or six straight hammer fist after hammer fist.
Do you think that this fight,
like the kind of beating that he took in this fight,
I mean,
you can only take so many of these meetings,
but this is a long time ago and he seems to be,
um,
okay,
now he seems to be,
well at the time he was like Jujitsu Savior.
Yeah.
You know,
it was my biggest hero.
Yeah.
I remember you used to get so fired up and this dude would fight.
He has like finally a dude who can finish people off his back.
Yep.
I'm a big fan of that and know that,
oh,
I need tags.
Bob Sapp right in the beginning of the first round,
the second round,
he's in way better shape going into the second round and now he's moving around
at boxing.
Oh Shit.
He's throwing down,
dude.
Oh,
he just got heavier than alive.
And while we're watching this,
I mean,
the crazy thing is the Japanese fans,
they hardly even cheer.
It's like real quiet,
respectful that I feel tired.
They have such a different way of,
uh,
appreciating fighting.
You know,
there are a lot louder now are they now know.
Americanized.
Yeah.
They're,
they're,
they're figuring out the Americans.
We did another culture.
We ruined their martial arts culture.
They're yelling at shit.
I don't even know what it means.
Like kick his ass,
sea bass on that shit out and have no idea what it is.
Sort of like a white guys with Japanese tattoos.
Yeah.
Stand them up.
Rough [inaudible] means that's hilarious.
There's been a couple of UFC.
I wish I had gone to the glory days of pride.
That's one of the things that I wish I saw you got to.
You were there,
you did commentary for the glory days,
man.
Pride 10.
Yeah.
Dude.
Who was the first card you,
uh,
you did commentary with?
Who's fine?
Ooh.
Shit.
That was pride Tan.
That was uh,
Vandelay Silva gets Guy Mascara.
Great fight water fight.
Henzel Sakharova okay,
hold on.
Yeah.
Hands up soccer robber.
Can you do this?
Do this,
do this.
He's locking in a bar.
Boom.
We got slammed.
He got slammed by Bob saps getting tired.
He's locking up a triangle.
You can't lock up the triangle.
No Way.
You can lock it up.
You can't lock it up.
He's going to have to switch.
I'm gonna switch to the arm bar.
Oh,
look at this.
what did he do?
Oh Wow.
I'll see.
Mighty good guys.
Too Big.
Who has more heart than Nogueira?
No one.
No one ever.
Oh,
this is what he did.
He got them from this peak out.
Yeah.
You remember he reversed them this way?
He's,
he did it before.
Early in the fight.
It worked.
He peeked out,
but he's tried it a couple times since then.
It hasn't worked,
I think.
I think that's how it gets done.
Yeah.
And now he's on his back.
Bob's house getting tired.
Oh my God.
It's so big.
So ridiculous.
No gears going for Kamora here.
I don't remember this.
I remember this at all.
Do you remember this?
I say Kamora this big dude.
Really?
Oh,
that's ready mountain from here.
Member.
He rolls them over with this Kamora.
He throws his,
when he,
when he's doing this,
he throws his left leg over the top.
That's how he gets them,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He sweeps and with this.
Yep.
Yep,
Oh Man.
Come on.
God.
In a movie.
Oh my God.
He said boom.
Pops up.
Pushed him right off.
Oh my God.
He swept him for one second.
Oh,
but now he's got his arm.
His right arm is in deep.
His right arm was in deep.
If he can hold his wrist there,
his right arm's deep across is going to do it.
Oh,
he's trying a triangle and to try and triangulate this work,
son.
Oh my God.
Wow.
He's holding on to that risk though.
It's amazing.
The Bob Sapp is still has gas,
right?
It is amazing,
but this is it.
This is where he got them.
That's I peaked out.
He's on top now.
Yeah.
Now.
Now he's in side control.
Oh my God.
And Bob Sapp can't breathe.
He can't breathe and now he's getting pounded on and they'll,
Garrett's punched him in the face.
He's going to take that left arm.
That is incredible.
At the time,
this was King Kong versus Godzilla man.
This was,
oh my God.
Then he sits back for the arm bar.
Everyone's going nuts at Larry's house right now.
We were losing our minds.
I'm like,
can you were screaming,
screaming?
Oh Man.
Oh
Dude.
Right there was,
everybody was going ape shit.
This was just a victory for technique.
A victory for Jujitsu.
That was a pure Jujitsu and end Nogueira.
You know Nogueira was like the perfect vehicle because he was so tough.
Dude.
That was the greatest fight of all time.
Yeah,
that's the greatest.
I think it's gotta be right up there.
It's gotta be right up there just for the sheer,
first of all,
the sheer fucking beating.
He went through man getting dumped on his head like that.
By that 350 370 pound guy smashes him down on his head like that.
Just to get through that man.
How'd that not put him out?
Almost
hammer fist.
He got hit with,
how about we were going to put them in that fuck bed.
A sketch we wrote for the man show over that he agreed to do it too.
It's right.
What was,
what were we going to say?
This sketch was the,
it was a commercial parody called the fuck bed.
And the commercial starts a really got guys banging some check this out
commercial,
sorry guys,
banging the chick.
The bed falls apart and it breaks and she goes,
you're a fucking asshole.
And grabs her shit and leaves and he looks at the camera's like,
Oh fuck,
you know,
it's bad brogue so that you come on,
he goes,
if this ever happened to you.
And then it's a,
it's a uh,
fuck bed that's built with,
uh,
for the frame.
It's like steel gurneys and the headboard was like Tatami mats and Shit.
And we're going to test it would tell you we're going to be like in a,
in a,
in those white coats,
testing it with a clipboard,
lab coat,
lab coat in.
There you go.
And Bob Sapp was going to be fucking blow up dolls testing the bed,
my fucking,
and then they'd be constantly blowing up and dudes giving them new blow up
dolls.
Yeah.
And Bob sat was totally down to do it.
Damn.
How the fuck,
that was another good you picked that.
Got kaboshed.
At the higher levels.
Yeah,
there's,
there was nobody like pop Sam,
Bob [inaudible] in his prime like that back in that fight.
That was a character in a movie.
Man.
He was a character in a movie.
He beat Ernesto hoost twice.
I mean,
you can take,
take,
you know,
say all,
we were so big and it was so much bigger.
That is true.
However,
it's Ernesto hoots and Ernesto,
who's dropped him and Lester,
who's dropped him with a fucking leg kick.
It dropped him once,
I think with a leg kick in once with a body shot.
So it wasn't like he didn't sustain damage.
He had a pull himself out of the fire to beat that guy.
He would have been perfect for WWE.
Right?
Fuck yeah.
Bob.
Slap God's man.
Vince Mcmahon is not doing his homework.
Well,
I just don't know how long you can stay that big.
You know,
it's,
you can't just stay that big forever in rock.
You know,
ones that big man.
No one's that bad.
Come on.
No one's ever,
no one's ever stayed that he wasn't that tall.
He was six,
four inches wide as hell.
Giant,
three 50 all muscle.
No Shit.
I've never seen a human being in life that was real,
that looked like Bob Sapp never,
there was nobody like him.
Just sheer size.
Like you could reach him,
he could put his arms out and just block everything you just said so much.
Man.
He got so famous in Japan,
he was like Michael Jackson famous.
He couldn't go anywhere.
When you go to Japan,
he would never leave his hotel room cause he sticks out like a sore thumb.
Yeah,
he would get mob left and right.
He was a huge,
huge star in Japan.
But apparently as time went on they started to having disagreements about,
you know,
financial issues and I don't know what happened,
but he walked out on a show,
they were trying to get him to fight without a contract or something like that.
And he said,
no,
I'm,
I'm wanting my contract first and then I'll fight.
And they said,
no,
no.
After the fight we'll give you a contract.
And he was like,
what?
Fuck this.
I'm leaving.
And so he left and then he was in trouble for a long time.
And that was sort of the last,
you know,
the last of the big Hurrah of Bob Sapp in Japan as you still fighting now.
I don't know where he's fighting though.
But you know,
in Japan that that run that he had when he was a huge national superstar,
you know,
he would sing songs and shit.
[inaudible]
he had like an album,
remember the commercial he did with the bananas?
Oh my God.
Yeah.
That was crazy.
Jap Japanese and racist.
Oh my God.
Not all of them.
I take that back.
They don't,
they don't understand some of the racist stuff that,
uh,
um,
the things that we would think are racist,
like Bob Sapp did up banana,
commercial.
Well,
I think,
yeah,
you know,
it's okay in their culture,
it's okay to like make a big Buckeye eat bananas because they don't have that
many big black guys over there.
So when,
when you have one for them,
they don't register how fucked up it is.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
I think also Japanese or like they,
they have,
they're really,
uh,
Japan centric,
you know,
Japanese people
really,
uh,
you know what I'm saying?
They,
they really focus on,
on uh,
on other Japanese people.
I wouldn't say they're racist.
They have a lot of unity amongst,
I take that back.
I didn't mean they're racist.
I meant well that it w that commercial that they put Bob Sapp in eating those
bananas.
Oh,
in America.
That would have been,
but just think of all the,
all the other freaky shit they do thinking about like the little girl's
underwears are not little girls,
but chicks underwears rather that you can buy and dispensers,
you know,
right next to a coke machine and they,
they,
they're into some different next level shit.
They're obsessed with little school girls in their outfits.
Yeah,
man.
I mean,
they're different,
you know.
So who's to say I love him?
I mean in there,
maybe they'd be there.
Right.
Maybe it is funny to watch Bob beat a bunch of bananas.
Hello?
Okay.
I had,
you know,
but whatever it is,
he was a,
at one point in time,
he was one of the fucking biggest stars in the country.
One day we'll,
we'll see pictures of Bob Sapp skinny.
You think so?
Like one 90 yeah.
You can keep that shit up.
You ever looked at pictures of Dorian Yates?
Now you know Dorian Yates is black guy.
No,
no.
Dorian Yates.
Yeah,
he's the,
he was the English guy who was the Mr Olympia.
One of the fittest guys of all time,
dude.
And he's really skinny now.
Yeah.
Now he's like busted out on the,
on the Internet.
Look for a picture if you could find it.
Dorian.
Dorian Yates.
I mean he was just immense at one point in time.
He now he's skinny.
Yeah.
Nobody's normal sized,
you know,
and you don't see any pictures of him now with his shirt off.
I think some of these dudes when they retired,
they just don't lift weights anymore.
They're like,
fuck this,
I'm done.
And good luck getting your balls to work.
Right.
Good luck.
What'd you do?
You jacked him to 10.
See this is him when he was in his prime.
We're looking at pictures when he was in his prime.
I mean he was fucking amends,
man.
That's not even him at its biggest,
but look out fucking big ears man.
There was,
there was him when he got even bigger.
Cause these guys,
they have to keep getting bigger every year.
Everybody else gets bigger and they get more defined and you know,
guys take things to the next level.
It's like this right now is sort of not that big in comparison to how guys look
today.
You know this is,
I mean not that long ago either.
And then Lee Haney came after him,
right?
Was it Dorian Yates and then Lee Haney?
Is that what it was or am I getting it confused?
Leanne?
He's a black guy.
Yeah,
look at that picture right there.
Click on that.
Click on that one.
No,
no,
no.
The one that you just had up here,
click on that.
Click on that.
Look at the fucking size of him.
Dude.
Holy Christ.
There's a picture of him with his little speedos holding another guy with his
little speedos.
They're holding hands and,
and he is so fucking enormous.
This was when he was at his peak.
He was probably 300 fucking pounds of muscle in here.
Man.
That's ridiculous.
I wonder how much she actually would go there.
A picture of him.
But there's a picture of him today.
Look up Dorian Yates.
Today's prion.
Stop doing that.
Gained me out man.
He's bouncing,
bouncing them up and down their little bikinis on.
So Eddie,
I haven't had a chance to talk to you about a,
um,
this,
this occupy Wall Street situation.
I'm going to take a piss because I have to.
Okay.
So have a little chit chat with Brian for the next 30 seconds and we come back
and want to know what you feel about this operation.
Wall Street Occupy Wall Street.
Shit up.
You're okay?
Is this him today?
Right here?
MMM.
Well no,
that can't be him today.
Okay,
that's crazy.
Imagine if you just looked down and saw that.
That's crazy.
So how the comedy gone?
Uh,
I have been so busy,
I haven't been writing,
so you still go up,
but I go up and they every week,
twice a week,
something like that.
Just keep going up.
Yeah.
You know,
it's crazy because a practice,
you know,
Steve Reynolds easy,
he did a Spiderman joke and which is one of my bits,
uh,
almost like I'm talking about coming into a hotel room and throwing it on.
He said the window,
but I say the walls,
but a got Spiderman.
So it's so weird that as a comic he see that other side of where you write
something and then you're like,
oh yeah,
you know,
but did he,
it's weird at first.
Oh,
I did at first,
but I didn't create Spiderman.
Like as in throwing com.
Yeah,
that's,
I've heard Patricia Neal say it before.
Uh,
w what now I've seen it like I've,
I've just used it.
Yeah,
I think,
well,
when I was a kid,
I used to call it like all my friends would call it spider manning.
So I don't think it was something like somebody just with,
like in 1997 I created Spiderman.
I think that's just like an old term or,
or maybe an old slang from the 80s.
Uh,
but yeah,
it's weird seeing that and it just,
it does make you just want to write more jokes and so it doesn't really matter,
but it's just weird seeing it.
Cause then anyone that saw that at that show,
I will know that joke already.
And then it sounds like I took it from the,
the show,
you know?
That's so weird.
What are you talking about?
I missed a Spiderman,
you know,
like that.
So they had a league the other day.
Yeah.
And you know what?
Apparently uh,
Patrice O'Neil had been doing that before.
Yeah,
that's why I was just saying spirit of meeting is actually,
it's a term.
Yeah.
So it's like saying a blowjob joke,
but the idea of doing it in a hotel room and throwing it on the wall,
it's kind of weird.
Well son,
sometimes you just gotta let Shit Go.
Have you had that happen?
Like,
just like,
like jokes being on TV and then you're like,
I don't feel like you've been doing that joke now because it feels like I'm
copying it off of the league.
Yeah.
If you come to the same,
especially if it's a quick one liner,
right?
Like an obvious one liner,
you know,
it's easily,
it's easy to,
for that to happen or,
and also,
you know,
for a lot of comics this,
this unfortunately it does happen where like writers of TV shows,
we'll go to see standups and they'll take a bit and I'll turn that bit into a TV
show.
Yes.
It seems like that happens a lot for like Sarah night live and shit like that.
I always,
your comics told them
because people are desperate.
They're desperate.
They want to keep that job.
And a lot of these writers,
same thing,
they're desperate and they want to keep their job.
Yeah.
I've had a couple of friends that got,
uh,
you know,
ripped off Kevin James was the funniest one.
Man.
Kenny,
Kevin James went to a,
um,
he had a big development deal with NBC and um,
when they have a big development deal,
they'll do shows and uh,
he'll do standup and for all these different writers and all these different
producers and they all tried to figure out what sort of a vehicle to develop
with them.
So,
uh,
he does his show and a year and a half later,
one of his bits is on Seinfeld and somebody,
I mean,
it's the fucking,
the taglines are the same.
I mean it was ridiculous.
Just kills the bit,
killed his bed.
He had,
he had a drop in the bed and you know,
I don't know that the guy saw him,
but I don't think it's coincidental that here's this really hilarious comedian
who has this bit about muffins,
about Muffin tops,
like you only like the top of the mountain.
And he had this whole detailed bit about it.
I'd known Kevin for years by that I,
I'd see it was like one of his strongest bits and then all of a sudden he does
it on top of these guys in front of these guys.
And somebody tasting gangs had for a TV show.
I don't know if that actually happened for a fact,
but it certainly
they seem like it happened.
Yeah,
it seems like it would be easy.
Yeah.
A lot of people probably guys gang I,
there's guys ganking ideas and then there's just parallel Todd,
which happened parallel thinking.
It's constant.
It's common,
so common,
you know,
especially in this day and age,
with all,
we all have this sort of the same access to information,
you know,
with Google and with the Internet and Twitter and shed when we have way more
access to information than ever before.
So it's really for someone to come to a similar conclusion to you is even more
likely today,
I think than ever before.
Right.
When you think,
well,
I mean in some ways,
but like with like with my instance,
it's like all right,
just having a crazy term like spider manning and then coming and throwing your
calm like on a wall or stuff like that.
Which in on the League it was the window that seemed really though,
dude,
cause dude,
it's a disgusting.
Okay.
And when dudes,
you would think that flinging your loads like Spiderman and make that thing,
you think you're the first person?
No,
no,
no.
I'm not saying that I'm the first person I think of that,
but I,
the joke of being in a hotel room and just doing anything in a hotel room and
throwing it on the walls at Spiderman,
on the walls,
white.
Honestly and I,
this is not meaning to be,
I don't even care.
I'm just saying that the idea,
the problem is,
my joke is out.
So I've heard a lot of comics talk about doing things in the hotel rose,
I'll ever heard a lot of comics talk about wrecking hotel rooms right now,
but doing Spiderman and on a hotel room and she seems kind of weird that they,
you know,
especially since,
uh,
yeah,
I know what you're saying,
but it's,
it's one of those things that could have,
they could have,
you know,
you never know.
They could have seen you do it
or they could have heard you do it rather,
or they could have just come up with it on their own.
Right.
Because you came up with it.
Right,
right.
It's all the idea of that in the hotel room.
Yeah.
That's disgusting.
Anyway,
and stop throwing your loads around you fucking free.
Maybe run a easy,
he's been hanging out with Carlson.
See Ya know
Steve is good guy.
Steve [inaudible],
he's the best.
He's aces.
He's good people.
And I saw him on that one shot.
I'm like,
Oh shit.
He's blowing up.
Yeah,
he is blind.
What does that show?
He's on legal.
Legal.
Yeah.
He's a good dude.
You read as easy as the funny guy,
just old school comic store,
old school.
He was one of the guys on the clip.
That video clip of Mitzi was one of the few guys that stood up to him and see
her back then and told them,
you steal jokes.
I remember we used to go to the comedy store every Goddamn weekend.
Yeah,
pretty much every weekend we were at the comedy store for gears for years.
Shit.
Yeah.
I developed my whole act there the whole day.
I didn't realize my,
how hostile my act wasn't till I stopped performing there.
I didn't realize.
I brought my act to the Improv and I was like,
man,
why am I so angry?
It's like,
you know,
the comedy store,
it just makes you,
makes you more angry,
man.
That's a haunted spot.
A lot of angry people there.
You know,
we saw so much crazy shit on that street,
man.
So,
so much crazy shit.
I started,
dude getting knocked the fuck out.
There's nothing more terrifying than watching a guy involved in a street fight
where you know,
he has absolutely no idea how to defend himself because this poor guy,
they would not want to say poor guy cause you see them or kind of a Douche.
Do remember that.
I remember that this guy was yelling at some other guy and we didn't see the
knockout.
We just saw him flailing like spastically.
I remember he,
he didn't even have his hands clenched fist.
He was just swinging and like literally closing his eyes.
And then,
uh,
a bus moved in front of him and passed.
And then when we saw the space,
he was flat,
unconscious out cold.
So we don't know exactly what knocked him out.
But watching this poor guy,
like a deer in the headlights,
just flailing for his life.
It was really terrifying,
man.
You know,
I remember thinking,
watching this guy do that,
like holy Shit,
like this poor guy.
He doesn't know how to defend himself at all.
And somehow or another he's in a fight and he's just spasming.
He's just,
he wasn't even thinking about what he's trying to deal.
He was just closing his eyes and flailing his arms.
Yeah.
And somebody knocked him the fuck out.
How about when David Lee Roth came by and checked you out at the counter?
That was fun.
He liked,
loved you.
Nobody liked talking about the good old days.
More than David Lee Roth.
He has some great stories.
I love talking about the old days.
He loved it.
It was,
and I loved hearing it.
It was amazing stories of how,
how he managed all the groupies back in the day,
the greatest ideas.
This is what he did.
I don't think you're supposed to sell.
I don't think he wanted people to know this stuff now.
Yeah.
Because remember his,
uh,
he had a guy who got in contact with a red band after is over cause we had video
of this and he's like,
I just want to make sure that none of that video gets out.
Remember that?
It was a long time ago.
Yeah know it was,
but you know what?
Maybe it's David Lee Roth,
just a loose cannon and this dude is like his manager that takes for him.
I don't remember that.
I remember I just ran,
but I wouldn't want to disrespect him if that guy called.
It might be,
he might have called because of David Lee Roth.
So I don't want to tell any of his stories.
I'm pretty sure that was the case and I'm pretty sure,
I'm pretty sure David Lee Roth is a bad motherfucker.
Holy Shit.
No one was more of a rock star than that guy.
And he entertained me and Eddie for shit.
He sat down and talked to us for over an hour telling just crazy stories on the
road and crazy stories are performing and it's,
you know,
it was awesome.
It was awesome.
That was one of the coolest like celebrity meetings ever.
He was so cool.
He was just hanging out,
man.
He just hanging out at the comedy store with his buddy.
They just came to watch some comedy and man,
when I tell you that wasn't even half full,
it wasn't even half folds.
A tiny ass little crowd.
Right.
There wasn't like a big place and he was just chilling and then he just hangs
out like a regular dude.
Man.
He had some great fucking stories of the old days,
man who would go on stage without bottle of Jack,
get out of hand.
That's it for me.
Shit.
It was so surreal because when I was in high school,
my my sister's boyfriend had van Halen was his license plate.
They were dedicated to van Halen.
Everyone in my high school was like dedicated to van Halen.
My brother that was his favorite band,
like my,
my bandwidth kiss and his band was van Halen and he would,
you know,
we would like battle,
like who would come out the best on the One van Halen started fucking crushing
and getting just powerful kick started turning disco.
And I was like,
fuck man,
it's amazing how van Halen changed.
They went from being this like really fucking bad ass wild ban to jumping Hagar.
No,
Sammy Hagar,
man,
that's a different fucking van Halen.
A completely different sound.
Like it was totally and super successful.
Even more successful than the old van Halen.
Did you know that?
Probably by this figure was I think,
I think this that I think the Sammy van,
hey girl,
Hey Sammy Hagar van Halen,
that is more successful.
I don't know.
Maybe now over over time of year like you know Paul they talking about in my ass
but I think someone said that.
But,
um,
I think their fifth album was the last time with David Lee Roth is 1984 and when
that came out and jump was our first single and they shot that video for like
600 bucks.
I was the story and is like,
you know,
real low budget video.
But the whole song was just really,
really,
I mean I never liked that song jump.
It was like a keyboard som but really cheesy like Yamaha dx seven old school and
like what happened?
Like he just came on set because Eddie van Halen was a guitar.
God,
everybody worshiped him and here he comes out playing keyboards and that just
freaked everybody out.
We weren't ready for synth like that in the early eighties Brock bands weren't
doing that shit unless it was like evil.
Mr Crowley,
like Ozzy,
they weren't putting in.
It was,
it was,
it took a big fucking chance and they blew the fuck up.
Yeah,
that was a huge hit.
Massive.
And then Panama was huge.
I had Amal was the shit that was a good fucking song that was like hot for
teacher summer party song hot for a mature teacher.
So dude,
Panama was the summer party song and that was when I was in those aisles.
Like in high school?
Yeah.
Classic Shit.
Eddie van Halen shredded.
He changed the face of guitar plan.
He just by himself in his came out and just when he,
when the first album when he did that song eruption,
it's just a guitar solo is on the first album was the second song and they
opened up and running with the devil and then they just before you really got me
they just gave Eddie van Halen.
Just two minutes.
A second song.
He just shredding.
It's an all time classic eruption.
Could you have imagined?
It's fucking amazing.
Could you imagine of TMZ was around during David Lee Ross,
you imagine how many fucking videos they have had a ham hammered coming out of
clubs.
That would have been great shit that we missed.
That would have been classic fun stuff too.
Cause every time David Lee Roth,
you put a camera in front of his face and he knew what to say.
He would just,
you know,
smart.
He had like sayings,
you know how they say you got the last that I can do it a little bit.
You know,
he was more,
more,
more can I need to hear him?
If I heard them,
I could do it.
He had great quotes.
Yeah,
he was real good at that.
He was real good at like,
he,
I thought he was going to make it as a radio DJ when they had him replace Howard
Stern.
Howard stern went to a satellite.
I was like,
wow,
what a bold move fucking daily rob.
But then I thought about,
I was like,
he's such a bad mother fucker who wouldn't want to talk to him.
You know,
let them go.
Like with David Lee Ross should do is just do a fucking podcast that that's what
he should do.
You know,
David Lee Roth podcast would be the shit.
Him and Joey,
dude,
are you kidding me?
Jelly.
Do the David Lee Roth should have an awesome fucking podcast.
You know he's a fun dude to talk to man.
Sign them red band.
No,
I don't think he does.
You check on Itunes,
the David Lee Roth podcast.
People come to you for podcast now and then you're like,
I don't have time to call Todd the pod.
Master the pod.
Father I hit.
Do you have to turn people down?
Plug best?
I do really well.
I'm the only one doing everything,
so it's really hard.
Oh,
he's blown the fuck ups on.
That's just how it is.
We do the Ice House chronicles his on his label now.
So on the desk quad label,
the icehouse chronicles,
the one we do from here,
we're all the stand ups that do the Ice House to come over.
We've got a show tonight folks too,
and it's not quite sold out.
If you want to jump on the issue yet,
it's Bill Byrd.
Joey Diaz,
Thompson Gora Brian at Thompson top score is not going to be Steve.
Oh Steve.
Oh uh,
no.
Tom's to grow.
That's Friday.
No,
Thomson [inaudible] Friday,
Friday.
Steevo.
Who else?
Uh,
Brendan Walsh.
God Damn,
that's a fucking show.
God.
That's a show.
Ladies and gentlemen
from 15 bucks.
Jamie Walsh doing standup,
I couldn't,
might all the sudden,
you know he wants to fight and I'm like,
let me take my pants off.
We can't talk about that.
That was a great story to remind me to tell because I don't remember all the
details.
You can't tell without his permission.
He didn't want to ruin me pants.
It's about the fucking thinks he can invest with me.
Just find the fucker got naked that he got naked.
Why did he get naked?
Mother fucker got naked and Paul God on me,
so I'm like,
wait a minute.
Long story,
we can't talk.
He got make it.
This guy is insane.
Did you guys call the psychiatric ward?
What happened?
Well,
I took off my pants first.
Wait a minute.
I didn't want to ruin my pants and underwear on and then he took off his pants
and underwear and he fucking pulled God on me mate.
I got like,
oh,
I see what happens is going to get some booty.
The guy's like,
you know what?
You think you're taking your pants off.
We'll check this out.
Get motherfucker.
Huh?
Maybe it could be that.
So I think it was just showing him off.
Maybe some gay shit though too.
We can't discount the possibility of gay and that scenario.
You know that seems like your guy was just hoping everything would go right.
And then he started crying.
Come on.
Which isn't like the mean streets of in an alley somewhere.
Was this
a hotel room?
Oh,
imagine if there was a clock somewhere that has accidental gay acts had showed
the number like the national debt and you can just see all the accidental gate
gay acts all day.
Dink,
dink,
dink.
Look Brian Collins story and any accidental gas.
Just a clock.
The universe recognizes when someone fuck.
Oh Jesus.
Oh what have you done?
That's a guy you got to get Brian Calendar.
Do his personal mean again cause he was the original Brazilian master.
You know
Brian Callan is ah,
is the original.
He does a perfect Henzel Gracie Brazil.
That's what he does.
He like talks like Kenzo.
Yeah.
Maybe you could pull that.
Pull ups.
Look,
pull up.
Ah,
not my car.
I don't think it's on there.
It's on youtube.
Jay Instructor.
Gay Porn.
Yeah,
something like that.
This is old school.
This is before you were,
we were at the UFC work bankruptcy before cause yeah,
when super first bought the UFC we were like,
Holy Shit,
you are the only celebrity that liked it.
So they gave you great seats.
So the first like three or four UFC,
we were sitting ringside enjoying it and they'd come up to you and get like a
quota.
Oh wait,
we're sitting here with Joe Rogan.
What do you think about the fights?
And then you would say something cool.
I think it's like human chess,
but instead,
you know something cool.
And then they would use that soundbite in commercials.
And then everyone loved the soup every,
you always had a great soundbite,
you know,
great analogy about the sport.
If boxing is this,
this is the,
you know,
and then gain.
I said,
dude,
you want to do some commentary?
And you're like,
yeah,
and you did commentary.
And I'm like sitting there by myself forever.
Yeah.
All this problem.
That became a problem.
So you,
you were like,
damn,
it sucks working by myself.
Maybe I could get you a job.
I don't see that video on line.
If you look right here to the right,
this is what comes up.
Bjj Instructor,
Gay Porn,
Cowen.
No,
don't put countdown put and it's right there.
It's right that right.
There's another one on top of it.
No,
the one.
That one right there.
Yeah,
that's it.
That's it.
Check this out.
Old School.
Brian Cowen before UFC at the MGM and this is,
it's like,
it's in a little tiny video.
I just take a guy sometimes
wouldn't do my man.
I may
want to talk to him like that.
Deep my hand now.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
Oh my God.
Can you split the call on the moon?
You have the sex times.
Guys don't understand for me.
Might go,
what I'm going to do now [inaudible] I can't get,
want to do barn or something.
Get my pool's.
Nah Man.
Get my book
making fucking moves in the air with
[inaudible].
Oh
my God.
That was one of the,
until Joey Diaz was on the Alex Jones show.
That was the funniest thing I'd ever seen.
It's true.
That was the funniest thing I'd ever seen in my life until Joe,
when Joey Diaz is on the Alex Jones show that just,
it was a,
that was done.
We see that or have you already played?
We played that at times,
but it's iTunes listeners are going to hate this episode.
Yeah,
we're sorry.
We're showing a lot of things and,
well we originally was supposed to be Joey and Eddie and I and we're going to do
regular,
uh,
and it's not all MMA,
but we're going to talk about that,
but may because it's the one request that we get all the time is doing MMA only
podcast.
So what we decided to do is try to make this one as much MMA as possible.
Uh,
and some of that,
unfortunately it's like visual.
Yeah.
Mason and maybe that shouldn't be a Joe Rogan experience.
Maybe that'll be like something else.
Um,
maybe because you don't want to
be listening to it,
like driving around,
listening to Sirius radio and going like what they were watching a video for a
half hour.
Yeah.
That's not a bad idea.
We maybe should have thought about that a moment that'll motivate them to go
watch the video.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
But yeah,
but that's also fine with,
yeah.
Well I think that might've been a boring 10 minutes for people that don't know
the history of it,
you know,
for us as we'll see.
We'll see what rolls out memory lane.
So I wanted to ask you about,
um,
this before I went to take a leak.
I want to ask you what the fuck you think about this occupy Wall Street shit.
What,
what,
what is your take on all this?
You're not,
to be honest,
I haven't really looked that deeply into it.
It just seems,
I don't know.
I mean,
it's definitely good,
right?
Anytime there's the people unite and try to change things,
that's always good.
Right.
You know,
but I don't know.
Well,
one of the reasons why I asked him,
because Europe,
I mean I've
never in my whole life had more conversations about 2012 Zacharias Cichon Beuru
Annunaki you and I have had more of these conversations at anybody and you and I
have had several of these Mayan calendar conversations and the end of the world
conversations,
and I hate to be like the guy who says it's all falling apart,
man.
It's all falling apart,
Yeah.
But if you look at it,
it's all falling apart,
man.
It's like how far can it fall?
Is there a safety net in there somewhere?
What do you mean we go bankrupt?
What happens when we go bankrupt?
I don't get it.
I'm missing something here,
man.
I don't know.
Is are the resources and the amount of people,
are those numbers vastly different than they were just a few years ago?
No,
they're not.
So what the fuck do we have to do to,
to re pump up the system to get it to the,
where it,
where it functions again or is it not possible?
Is it that in order for the system to function overall,
some places have to be bad in some places have to be good.
Is that,
is that,
is that the case?
I mean is it,
is it that,
no,
we can't like be even all across the country and therefore the American way of
life can't be sustained because the American way of life is only possible if
people in other parts of the world have to work for shit money and make the
products that we absorb.
Right.
It seems like you put it all together.
It seems like the powers that be Hollen asked to siphon as much money as they
can.
For some,
it doesn't seem that with like all this money just being taken and trillions of
dollars are going missing from the Pentagon,
like two point $3 trillion disappears and that was on the Jesse Rune Tierra puts
furry,
no,
that,
that was in that,
but it's really like Donald Rumsfeld the day before nine one one they said,
you know,
we have a big problem.
The enemies here,
enemies here,
and then the next that he announces that there's two point 3 trillion.
I think all of those are the numbers.
It's like 2.3 or 3.1 some kind of trillions and he announces this the day
before,
nine one one and he's going to do something about it.
You're going to look into the Pentagon,
they're going to look into the accounting and all that shit.
The day before,
nine one one and it was just stealing trillions unaccounted for.
They go,
we don't know where these two point $3 trillion.
It just seems like they're just going out of the way.
Well,
how about the most recent one where they said there was billions of dollars of
missing in Iraq and then they go,
oh no,
actually we found it and the Iraqis were kind enough to watch over it.
Guarded for us.
Yeah,
the fuck you did the fuck you did.
Fuck.
You found that at sound?
Some billions of dollars just laying around what they would just garden.
You didn't know where it was and they just had it in a room somewhere for you.
Oh,
we're just waiting for you to ask.
Rumsfeld announces on,
on on September 10th and then the next day the accounting office blows up and
the pedagogy,
some say it was a plane,
some say it was a missile,
whatever the heck the next day all the records are gone.
I mean it just seems like,
I'll tell you what man,
that nine 11 there's never a better case for confirmation bias then that nine 11
September 11 you know,
confirmation biases when you only look at one side of the argument because
you're trying to convince yourself that you're right.
And in the September 11th one man,
that's one where people just,
no one wants to admit that even the possibility that the government somehow knew
about it or somehow was involved in organizing and no one would ever,
ever,
ever admit that.
And if you admit that like you're a piece of shit.
Yeah.
You know,
that's,
it's a real tricky thing.
Like they don't want to look at the facts of the past.
They don't want to look at things like operation Northwoods or the Bay of Pigs
are all the different times where it might have been a bunch of bullshit while
we were in some country and one while young people were getting killed for
their,
their crazy bidding.
That might've been bullshit that we would have never agreed to if we knew what
the fuck was really going on.
Yeah.
But for whatever reason,
you know,
people don't want to look at that.
They don't want to look at that possibility.
It's incredible.
The amount of evidence there is that there nine one one was super shady.
I mean the fact that most people don't even know three sky sky scrapers went
down on nine 11.
Most people they'll tell you to,
you ask them how many skyscrapers went down.
Three went down.
They just don't talk about tower seven.
That was a like a 50 storey skyscraper.
They just imploded like a controlled demo.
You could look at it and it looks like a criminal controlled demo.
You'll look at it,
you see it,
it's on video.
Bunch of different angles.
And they didn't talk about it in the,
the,
the initial nine one,
one commission report.
They didn't even talk about why this skyscraper went down after years of
pressure and people go,
what the fuck happened to tower seven?
Why did it look like,
why was it demo to go?
It fell at free fall speed.
Everyone kept saying it fall that feel free.
Fall speed.
Explain.
People wanted
after.
So finally the government hired,
uh,
I think they're called [inaudible].
Um,
[inaudible].
It's like initials for some scientific company that's funded by the government,
NIST,
NIST and I.
S.
T you could see the videos on youtube unless they've been pulled.
And there they had a press conference and to explain what happened to this 50
story or it's like 47 storey skyscraper that just on video got controlled
Daimler ago.
It fell at free fall speed and they're staying there.
So they came up and to prove that it wasn't free fall speed,
that if it was free fall speed that it would,
it would've,
it would've fell in 4.2 seconds instead of,
you know,
4.4 seconds or some ridiculous thing like that.
Like there were a second off.
So there was just there to prove that it wasn't free fall speed.
So therefore there's no conspiracy.
So they go,
so wait a minute,
what,
so do any controlled demo,
any controlled demos,
do they fall at free fall speed?
None of that got the definition of free fall speed is something,
this is what they say,
something falling without any resistance.
That's free fall speed.
So this building had resistance so it's not free fall speed.
So they call the wait a minute.
Ridiculous.
It wasn't ridiculous.
There's mass.
Yeah,
of course.
Do some boots that stood up and said,
so wait a minute,
so do control demos.
Would you consider that freefall speed's other?
And they go,
nope,
that's not free fall speed.
Oh feel controlled demos are not free fall speed.
So why are we talking about this?
Yeah,
what is that?
It was ridiculous and you would just tell they just had it
her job.
That's fascinating that nobody thought anybody was going to counter that and
asked them if controlled demolitions or free fall speed.
Yeah.
I don't know if that was a controlled demolition because obviously I'm not an
architect to nor do I know anything about building structure.
So it is possible that you know you could burn a building and the fire reaches
so high and it's so hot that all the floors collapse uniformly and it pancakes
into itself.
It is possible.
I don't know,
based on you know,
architects and engineers for to live in truth,
they don't think it's possible.
Yeah.
That's 1300 just common sense.
Just common sense.
This is a video of a controlled demo and no other buildings you just put like,
like a detective.
No building has ever fallen like that ever before.
Do you think they armed the building when they built it?
What do you think they did if you thought,
if you think that's a controlled demolition,
what do you think they did?
Did they and it'd be I man everybody like there's a lot of people right now
getting angry.
It's a fucking bullshit conversation.
You fucking conspiracy theorists.
Listen,
I don't know.
I'm not saying I literally have no opinion on it,
but when I look at it,
it does look like a controlled demolition.
Does that mean anything?
No,
because I'm an idiot.
I'm not some sort of an engineer or any sort of a scientist.
However,
why does everybody get mad when you say it looks like a controlled demolition?
Yeah,
cause it fucking does.
that's true.
Fucking does.
Why are they mad?
Why you mad when I say that?
Someone that goes to the kinks in the middle and then falls into its own base
instantly.
Instantly.
All at what it does,
it all crumbles.
Everything gives out at the exact same order.
Like it just like it wasn't a controlled demolition and all gave out Florida
floors.
Perfect.
It looks exactly like a control down fell into its base.
No other one's saying it's a controlled demolition.
I don't know.
It's a controlled demolition.
You don't know.
Right.
It's like it looks like one minute look like one,
right?
It does.
Right.
But why does everybody get mad when you say it looks like a controlled
demolition?
Just look at it,
look at controlled demos.
There's plenty of video on them.
And then look at tower seven it's all on youtube.
You could just watch it.
No skyscraper ever has fallen like,
like that from fires.
It could be that,
you know,
if it gets damaged the way that got damaged.
And apparently that was also the,
the house diesel fueled there and there's like some sort of a lawsuit because of
that.
So they're saying like the diesel fuel led to,
you know,
the fire being so hot that everything collapsed like that.
It possible still it looks like a controlled demolition.
You don't believe that.
But it could be.
But what minimum you see.
But if they did really have like who knows how many gallons a fucking diesel
fuel,
you know,
thousands of millions,
who knows and that stuff is on fire.
That's an incredible amount of heat that would be generated.
That does make sense that it could compromise the structural integrity of a
building of,
it's all a bit of it's base becomes an oven.
If I had a bet $1 million either when we were going to find out the answer and
you have to guess,
I would definitely go,
okay,
this is,
I would say controlled demolition,
controlled demolition.
There's a lot of shady shit going.
Here's where it gets really crazy in the war started after that.
It was a way to get into the wards.
So here's where it gets really crazy.
That was that building was where the NSA had offices.
The CIA had offices did tower tower ellogence had all kinds of like secret
fucking black ops shit going on in there.
You know what?
Let me tell you a little story.
Let me tell you.
Choose Joe if you're doing the same yes or no question that he did.
You know,
like we're going to find the answer out right now.
What do you mean?
If it was a controlled demolition,
what would I do?
What do you mean?
What would she choose?
Oh,
if I had to say one,
one or the other,
whether it was or not.
That's a good question.
Um,
it looks like a controlled demolition.
You know,
I don't,
it doesn't make sense.
This is one $9 trillion dollars.
1 million for me,
10 billion for him
and Billy,
and it's fucking really hard to guess,
man.
It'd be really hard to guess because honestly it sounds preposterous and this is
this my la,
you know,
outcomes,
razor logic,
all that stuff.
When I think the fact that they might have hired a whole crew to rig this
building with explosives or maybe construct the building with explosives built
in,
like,
does anybody do that or is it possible that this fucking two planes slammed into
these giant towers caused all this fucking damage to neighboring buildings and
it started a fire and the fire lit up these gasoline drums that were filled with
diesel fuel and there's millions of gallons of fuel in the whole thing inside of
it became like a fucking oven and just gave out all at once.
Shit,
I got to go with,
got 10 seconds,
Joe.
I got to go with controlled demolition.
Yeah.
Fuck yeah,
you'd go a controlled demolition.
If I had to one way or the other,
I absolutely don't know.
But if I,
if I would be surprised if
it was proven that it was a controlled demolition.
Sorry,
you both lost guys.
The true answer was two planes just crashed in there and there was a lot of fuel
in that building and everyone's Jason,
you know,
that's a true fact though.
It is.
It's just true.
You'd be surprised that not only do most regular people right here and awesome
argue or know about tower seven.
Check this out.
I'm at grapplers quest right now.
One of the refs,
um,
after in the middle of the show we,
we uh,
we started talking about,
I don't know how it came up,
but he said he used to work for the FBI and then he got out of that Shit and
then you started working with Brian Simmons and with a grappler,
squats and all that stuff.
And I go,
so what do you think about,
he started telling me how that went.
You know,
he had like shit jobs.
I guess FBI is not glamorous dude.
When nine one one happened,
guess what I had at bucket duty?
I had me at ground zero,
just putting shit.
I was doing nothing.
That was no investigative work.
We were just all out there just picking up trash.
Man is like,
he's like talking about FBI being,
imagine how much time it took to clean up 200 story skyscrapers,
garbage dude.
I would have taken like 100,000 Mexicans.
They would have finished that shit.
I got month,
but anyways,
go there and he's allowed to say he's allowed to scan,
let's take advantage of that Mexican
liberal with that.
But uh,
he was telling me this like fog.
It was like we were on bucket patrol.
FBI's so not glamorous.
It's not like it is in the movies brought trust me and I go,
so what do you think about tower seven,
man?
What do you think?
And he goes,
what do you mean tower seven?
I go,
you don't,
you know that tower seven,
there was a third tower that went down and didn't get hit by a plane,
is a third one that went down.
You know,
I said,
you know,
the CIA had offices in their navy,
intelligent and Ron,
all that.
And he goes,
Oh
man,
you know what their problem is getting rid of a lot of evidence.
Miss.
That's what he said.
He goes,
goes up top.
They just,
they're just trying to get rid of,
that's what his,
he didn't even know about it.
Could you imagine if that's really what they did?
If they rigged the building to explode to get rid of evidence,
shady stuff that they've been,
yeah,
but wait a minute,
do you think,
I mean how,
how deep you are willing to take it.
You want to take this with a guy to happen?
This is what the guy told me.
You know what I mean?
And this guy,
no,
well that makes sense with that building.
But how deep you willing to take it?
Are you willing to take it?
Do you believe that they could have let nine 11 happened?
They could have let those people fly those planes into those buildings?
Well I think they,
the,
I would,
if I had to guess,
it would be something similar to what they were going to do in Cuba.
They were already going to do something like that and like,
you know,
even Vietnam and Pearl Harbor,
they,
you know,
government first,
maybe it's not even the government is people on over the government.
They need reasons to get into war.
We need the people behind it.
We need people waving American flags.
So w you know,
it's,
it's standard building empires one on one.
Yeah.
They actually moved some of their warships out of the navy base
in Hawaii because they knew that they were going to be attacked.
Yeah.
Move valuable ships.
Americans did not want to get into World War II.
We got into World War II,
B after the Japanese rated Pearl Harbor.
But we had known the Japanese.
Apparently the government supposedly had known,
I mean this was on the history channel.
They were talking about it nowadays.
Back then it was a conspiracy theory.
Now it's mainstream knowledge now that,
that,
uh,
America knew about and they let it happen.
They go,
perfect.
Well,
let them come in here and what the fuck they needed to get into the war.
The imagine the mindset that you have to have to allow US soldiers to die and
will allow them to die knowing that you're,
you're to manipulate the whole situation and bring people into more Northwoods.
Explain that really quick.
This is 1962,
the joint chiefs of Staff signed a document that was what they were gonna do was
they were gonna arm Cuban friendlies and have them attack one Tanam obey,
could have easily killed US soldiers.
Right.
They were gonna put a drone plane in the air and blow it up and blame it on the
Cubans and that was going to make people want to go to war with Cuba.
They were,
there was all these different things that they were doing to uh,
get people enthusiastic about going to war.
Man,
that's real.
Yeah,
that's right.
At the fast sign by the joint chiefs.
It wasn't like an idea that someone came up with it.
Everybody wants,
so I get the fuck out of here.
No,
they signed it and put it together.
Kennedy's as a plan.
Yeah.
Kennedy vetoed it.
So it's happened before,
you know,
it happened with Northwoods.
It happened in Pearl Harbor and you know,
no one went to jail.
That's what's really important,
man.
Getting into Vietnam,
that was all shady.
That was like some fake attack that look how we got into Iraq and Afghanistan.
Zach.
I mean,
I had a whole bit about that,
about like that people will feel like what they told on one.
Yeah.
How does,
yeah.
But I,
yeah,
sure.
But doesn't make any sense.
I mean like why I was talking to a friend of mine last night,
he's a really good guy,
but he's,
you know,
he's like real kind of Rah Rah.
And we were having this conversation about why we're in Afghanistan.
I go,
do you see a threat in Afghanistan?
When was the last time they even talked about like the,
the war in Afghanistan being,
because there's a threat and you know,
I hear about Afghanistan,
I hear about trillions of dollars in minerals and he'll hear about 90% of the
world's opium.
I hear about natural gas pipelines the Soviet Union wants to control.
I hear about all these incredible resources that this place has.
And then the whole countries like in this state of chaos,
you know,
I mean it's like one city and then a bunch of like warlords,
man.
I'm like,
what?
What were over there for what reason?
What do we,
what are we doing?
It's basically like if your wife cheated on you three times over your marriage,
and then there's all this evidence that she's doing it again and you're like,
no way.
She would never do it.
Wait,
there's evidence.
It's not just we have like video evidence of her sucking the deaths and,
and you don't think she's shooting?
Oh,
the lighting and the shadows,
Bruh.
Ah,
you know,
shot bro.
Yeah.
It's that real.
I could do that.
Anybody can do that,
man.
So he's the enemy.
Our government has done this several times.
It's fact and we'll no,
no,
no.
Nine one one was not niching insane of tower seven went down like a controlled
demo.
No plane hit it.
Oh,
it was a flyer like Jesus Christ.
That's incredible.
But it's way sexier to think that it was a controlled demo.
It's way sexier.
Thank that.
There's a bunch of dudes sitting there and they go pull it,
pull it,
and they hit the button and the whole way imploded and then they go,
don't worry about it.
Who's gonna?
Who's gonna know we're gonna,
we're gonna have to talk about this.
Don't worry about it.
I got it covered.
Yeah.
You know,
I wish,
I wish.
I wish our government,
like everyday our officials woke up and said,
you know,
we got to get together and we got to make it better for the people.
What are we going to do?
We're going to make the best country ever.
You know what I mean?
We're going to make the best concerts ABC after school special on.
I wish it was like that.
That's how it was in 1776 are are,
I mean,
look at JFK and all that shit.
You,
you put it all together and our government has every government really,
it's just like every government basically as a history of massive corruption.
These were in a corrupt government.
How could you not see that?
To See Putin get booed in Russia.
That's deep dude fade or beat up Monson and asteroids.
Putin got into the ring and congratulated fake door and thank Monson and I
didn't see that and they were booing him,
man.
He gave a speech.
He started talking.
They were booing him,
man,
because they're fed up,
man.
They're fed up with this guys pushed himself back into power.
You know,
he was supposed to be elected and then his talk was over and then that was it.
But he's like right back in the mix.
He never gave up power.
It wasn't about to,
that's a gangster dude.
Pollutants.
Putin is a bad motherfucker.
Judo black belt guy goes hunting and fishing and shit.
That's a man dude.
Yeah.
That's why everybody was terrified when the thought of Sarah Pailin actually
being the president.
Cause what if Putin,
I mean Putin is a God damn man.
If
Sarah Palin actually became president,
what if they get an office?
What if by some fucking stroke of the imagination,
what for whatever reason her and what's his face?
Get an office.
What's his name?
Brian.
The Guy who ran with Sarah Palin.
Jesus Christ.
John Mccain.
John Mccain had a brain fart.
John Mccain and Sarah Palin when go into office.
John McCain is an old man.
He's been around a long time.
I mean he's,
he's voc gets really old and you know,
I respect the guy and he was a war here on all that stuff.
But that's,
he's,
uh,
he's a very old man.
And to have that as his running mate,
that's his vice president.
So if he dies,
she becomes president.
So,
you know,
easily you look at it.
Wow.
Obama's turning gray.
Man,
Obama's getting great quick.
Have you noticed that dude looks tired all the time.
If that was John Mccain,
he might be dead.
So right now he gives out.
Boom.
Sarah Pailin has to sit down at a fucking negotiating table with Vladimir Putin.
Could you imagine,
could you imagine how that killer would stare down that Nimrod?
Imagine that conversation,
the between this international bad motherfucker and some big bat who doesn't
even read
you.
Imagine what that conversation would be like.
God Damn.
So what do you think about Ron Paul?
I think Ron Paul is a very sensible man.
He believes in some strange things.
He's very religious,
but his overwhelming belief in the constitution is more important to me than
whatever religious beliefs that he has to have,
you know,
to get him through his day or,
or you know,
chooses to subscribe to or whatever.
For whatever reason he believes in,
you know,
uh,
creationism and a lot of those other things.
He doesn't believe in the theory of evolution.
There's a lot of things and he doesn't believe in is fine with me.
I don't,
it doesn't bother me because his belief in the constitution and his belief in
what America really should be,
that we wouldn't,
shouldn't be the police of the world.
That we shouldn't be wasting our resources and all these different countries
that we should be strengthening up our country,
our inner cities,
our structures,
our business or manufacturing,
pull all that resources and stop giving it to,
uh,
all these fucking gigantic war companies because that's what their are,
their war profiteers.
And the war profiteers of hijack the whole system and the pharmaceutical
companies have hijacked the fucking drug laws so that there's a disproportionate
amount of people that want things that are in jail.
Because they want them because they're not sanctioned by the government and they
become nonviolent drug offenders when you know,
they could just get the prescription pill form and they'd be just as fucked up
and fine.
You know,
they,
they can't choose to do what they want to do.
That's the whole package is bought and sold.
So when you step in,
if you're,
if you're a president or a presidential candidate who have fucked,
you aren't man,
good luck.
Good luck fixing this mass.
Good luck fixing this tangled fishing line.
It's pretty amazing watching the debates and anybody that speaks that besides
Ron Paul,
you just,
it's like total bullshit.
Every,
everybody just nothing but bullshit.
And then Ron Paul,
that's like a real dude who's breaking it down in,
honestly,
he,
you know,
his whole drug policy that's pretty,
that takes big balls that come out like that with his drug policy.
You know what I mean?
And,
and well,
there's evidence in other countries,
Portugal,
less people are addicted to drugs.
Less people are involved in prostitution because they made it illegal.
They made,
they may drugs legal.
They just said,
the fucking,
let's just decriminalize the whole pack.
That's what Ron Paul wants to do.
So it should be,
man,
you can't nanny state the fucking world.
Keep it from your kids.
Keep it from your communities.
You know,
and you know,
if people are selling and if they're pushing it there,
even if you feel like,
you know,
you can keep them out of your community,
man,
you know,
you could,
there they're criminals who should get rid of them,
but people who have it,
let them do whatever the fuck they want,
man.
Let them do whatever they want.
That's how it should be.
You know,
if you're,
they're not hurting you,
let them do it.
Let them do everything.
Let them try heroin.
I think it's stupid.
You want to do it?
Go ahead.
And I support it.
I don't want my kids to do it.
I'm going to try to educate them as much as possible.
Stay the fuck away from heroin,
but ultimately they can get it.
They can get it.
Anyway.
We are going to vote for
no,
that's who you gonna call Brian that form.
Awesome.
Uh,
Herman Cain just for a Goof,
not Ron Paul.
I think the whole thing's right.
Um,
yeah,
I'll vote for Ron Paul.
Sure.
But you know Ron Paul is probably not going to get into the position to be the
Republican nominee,
so I have to register as a Republican,
which is just gross.
Do you think they'd gone out of their way,
the media to ignore them?
Sure,
of course they are.
I saw one show,
this was the most hilarious version of it.
They were talking about how Mitt Romney at the time and Rick Perry,
we're battling out for the second and third spot there.
So battling out for number two and number three,
and then they started going into this whole battle between number two and number
three and what Mitt Romney needs to deal with.
Rick Perry needs to do it all the while ignoring Ron Paul because he was number
one.
They didn't even talk about Ron.
They just talked about these two dudes battling out for two and three and who's
going to emerge?
Why do you think the media is ignoring him?
Cause he's not media centric.
He's not,
he doesn't do anything that all these giant corporations want.
Everything that he says is like a utopia,
you know,
dream state where the military industrial complex doesn't really have control
over Congress and the politicians and everyone at the top of the heat bit.
But they really do.
They really do.
So what happens when he gets in place?
What happens when they put him in office and you know,
and then they go,
we're going to do what we're going to get out of us yet.
Afghanistan,
the fuck we are.
Sit Down Dude.
And then what happens?
Exactly what does he go on TV and tell it everybody,
you know,
they were just going to get them killed.
I mean what's going to happen then?
Is it going to be revealed that we actually live in a 100% complete police state
and now unfortunately because of Mr Paul's death,
the bullshit facade gets dropped and we just fucking march people into camps.
Don't you think they should read you the prejudice,
but don't you think they should read you?
The whole president thing where there's like multiple presidents,
like three.
That's a good idea.
A team of presidents is a good idea.
Know really the idea is based on tribes and monkeys.
It's really stupid.
It's great for 50 monkeys.
It's not good for 300 million human beings.
They have one person reside over everyone.
One person be our representative and we don't trust them enough to give them
more than of a four year stretch at the time.
You know,
we don't trust him to keep doing it and after eight years you're done.
Get the fuck out.
It doesn't matter if you're the best at your job of all time.
The temptation for corruption is just too powerful.
We will not allow the best person for the job to continue to have this job.
We won't allow them.
Even though the person who is probably best at the job has the most experience,
it doesn't have to be briefed,
doesn't have to.
Gino is,
is willing and able to continue it.
Bill Clinton would've done another four years.
The let them,
they're not,
I'm sorry.
Next guy moving in and we get to the next crook and town and this guy has got
his gang with him as Dick Cheney and Halliburton.
They come with fucking shovels and bags and he's stealing everything.
Dad,
Dah,
Dah.
That's the funniest presidency of all time.
Ceo of Halliburton accompanied that makes its money by fixing shit after the
United States blows it up in war.
They get hot fucking billions of dollars and no bid contracts to fix stuff after
we blow it up because the guy who used to be their CEO wants to go to war and
Afghanistan and Iraq,
so he forces everybody to go to war.
He forces Bush into it.
They make fucking ans insane amounts of money and somehow or another,
the whole thing takes place in front of everybody's eyes.
If that's delay,
a brilliant jacking,
what is I think gangster,
think of that.
How could that even be legal?
How could it even be legal?
The idea,
the only way it could be legal,
as you would have to assume that this person for sure is incapable of doing
something inhumane,
like going to war for any reason other than the fact that American lives are in
danger.
There's no way they would go to war for just for profit.
That's unheard of.
So that has to be assumed.
Otherwise it couldn't.
It couldn't be allowed.
You wouldn't allow someone who was once a CEO of a company that fixes up shit.
We blow up to just start taking over and blowing things up at an unprecedented
rate.
Oh,
what a coincidence.
This guy as the vice president,
and now we've blown up more shit than ever in history.
Woopsies between totally coincidental.
Don't worry about that.
That guy doesn't have a heart anymore,
man.
They're going to electric heart in there pumping his shit.
He's got some crazy pacemaker where he doesn't have a pulse.
It's just kind of pump.
So his body is just pumping blood like literally he's a,
he's a Zombie Dick Cheney's like an antichrist Zombie.
He's got no heartbeat.
Think of that.
I mean is that not in the scriptures,
man,
a man who walks with no heartbeat and feels no remorse for the millions of
deaths.
That shit could have been the scriptures that easily could be in the scriptures.
Turn on your hard loud.
Those motherfuckers took us to war from money and an amazing number that we've
always done it.
People have always done that.
Remember that one bit or talk at my George Bush and how dummy.
Yeah,
we can go down there.
Yeah.
He know what they did with Sarah Palin.
They did go in gum or wow.
You know,
somebody took that and make that um,
clip from my 2005 special,
they took that clip and added it to 'em up a picture of Sarah Pailin at the end
and it said like,
really?
Yeah,
we can go dumber.
Can we see that?
Oh you it man,
you will find it.
No,
I don't want to play it anyway.
I don't want to hear myself to stand up for herself out.
Especially from 2005 I was like a little too little too yeley little too yet.
What's the word as your early,
early Rogan,
who's the man all the time,
early rogue,
angry before the weed really found it to be a tremendous waste of time.
Now I'm still occasionally angry,
but more,
more tongue in cheek than ever before.
At why?
As you get older,
till you start thinking way.
I've got to pick the things I'm mad at,
man,
because you can get mad at everything all day if you really want to.
I know people to get mad at everything all day.
You ever see people that are in relationships who get mad at everything all day?
Girls Nitpick it guys.
And the guy who fucking fires back and you go,
wow,
you guys are not handling this so well.
And then you guys are handling this kind of silly.
You don't have to do this.
You know,
that's,
that's hard.
It's hard to watch,
man.
Especially when people have kids.
Dude,
that's when it gets hard,
dude.
That's when it gets hard.
I'm gonna Front,
I got a friend who's got a kid and him his wife.
The,
um,
the,
you seem like they seem like an electric trailer.
[inaudible] they seem like they're,
they're both upset at each other.
Do I know him?
Yeah,
I know he talking about some fortunate,
you know,
it's like God damn,
you guys get this beautiful situation here.
You should love each other.
Come on,
get it together.
You know what?
Either one of them smoke weed.
That might be a part of the problem.
Right?
I think everybody needs a little weed man.
A little perspective.
Just a little perspective enhancer,
you know,
don't you think when you smoked me like smoking weed with your girl doesn't know
that this is a nice thing.
Yeah,
that's the best thing,
right?
It's like you,
you like,
you chilled together,
you know,
you hang out together.
It feels better when you kiss each other.
You know,
it's like a,
a super sensitivity drug,
you know,
makes you super sensitive man.
He makes you really,
really liked that person.
You know,
all their good qualities get accentuated.
You really appreciate them.
Almost like you're seeing with new eyes
or you can get really paranoid freak the fuck out all the dot.
Guys.
I was watching as here,
here.
Phantom buzzes for guys texting her and her phone.
Oh Man,
I've,
I've had some serious,
uh,
anxiety attacks now.
I was watching cops last night and it was like,
yeah,
I've had at least five.
Firstly,
the biggest anxiety attack.
Sorry to break your hold onto that dog.
Brian.
I want to hear these anxiety attacks.
I never smoked pot growing up just once a year.
Sorry Brian.
Get in there.
No,
I'm good.
Don't be scared of me.
I have to get on stage and solve it.
That's perfect dude.
It's early.
It's only eight 20 man chosen star for two hours.
Yeah,
get in there son.
Plus we're going to go get some food after this.
We gotta hurry.
People are getting start getting here at nine.
Why are they getting here an hour and a half early.
What did it do?
They uh,
chronicles.
Yeah.
Oh,
who's coming in at nine?
I just told everyone to come in as close as nice as possible.
Oh,
okay.
So they'll all be here around 10 like last time in high school,
I didn't smoke weed.
I like I said once a year at a party or something,
and I would always get paranoid wasn't into it at all.
I did not like smoking weed at all.
Growing up.
11th grade at lunch,
there was a big stoner crowd.
There's probably like a hundred people in the stoner crowd and everyone thought
I was a stoner cause I hung out in the stoner crowd.
But if you look closely,
I was like on the edge.
I wasn't really in windows in man.
That wasn't really it.
It appeared I was,
but actually wasn't hanging out with him and just me and three other guys on the
side.
And one day I got pulled into the crowd and they're passing around a joint and I
said,
fuck it.
I didn't want to be a Douche.
I was kind of like stoked that they pulled me in,
smoked a little bit of weed,
is that lunch and I walk to my next class and I sat to noon,
noon,
dude,
I sat down.
I was little [inaudible].
Yeah,
exactly.
So it was history and I'm sitting there was US history.
I'm so fucked up out of my mind.
I'm like,
I freaked out.
I was getting paranoid.
So I thought,
how am I going to get through this class?
So I got just look straight.
Don't look at anybody,
just look straight.
Don't do nothing.
I go,
Oh my God,
I'm freaking out,
but I'm not.
No one's gonna know.
No one's going to go.
And then I look to the side and there's people are looking back on [inaudible]
this,
my eyes got fucking,
they said they were people like turn it around pointing at my eyes.
And I'm like,
fuck,
don't look at me.
Please don't,
don't bring attention to everyone's laughing.
I'm like fuck.
And then some girl handed me or compact or look at your eyes.
I looked at my eyes and they were so red.
It was fucking like a zombies eyes.
You have,
um,
you have contacts.
Did you have contact?
No.
No,
I didn't have contacts back then.
Did you have glasses?
Like black frames?
Yes,
I did.
I did work every now and then.
Every now and then.
But not to school fog now,
but my,
I looked at at,
at my eyes and I three doubt,
I just stood up and walked out of class and when to the bathroom and I sat on
the bathroom floor.
Meanwhile,
everyone's in cloud and I sat on the bathroom floor just freaking out,
like just panicking like I was on crack or something.
Just shit on the bathroom floor.
The teacher calls the,
the campus cop total Azel big ass mustache.
Total asshole.
He opens the door.
Yes.
What else does he opens the Lego.
You put those two together.
Total ass hole.
Big Ass.
I'll never forget him.
He opens the bathroom door and I'm sitting down and he opens.
It goes,
what are you doing in here?
And I immediately started crying.
I'm
like,
I pretend like I was sick.
And everybody had known that I like,
I was fucked up on weed cause the teacher knew that everyone was laughing.
I just walk out of class.
He grabbed me by the neck,
pick me up and drag me to the principal's office and I'm like,
I just started crying.
So just pretending that I was sick and he knew I wasn't sick.
So he brought me to the,
uh,
the principal's office.
He had a toupee on,
it was awesome and he was really cool.
Here he goes,
what's wrong?
I go home sick.
I hate a bed,
corn dog.
I'm sick.
And he goes home and the cop was like,
it wasn't bonded at all,
but the principal just looked at me and said,
all right,
let him go home.
And he just let me go home.
And I just walked home,
like all fucked up.
I got home,
just laid down on my bed and I'll never forget looking at the VCR clock,
just watching the minutes click by just,
I couldn't wait.
It just seemed like it was gonna last forever.
Just watching the clock please feeling go away.
I hate,
I hated it.
Yeah.
I only got high up maybe a dozen times before I started getting high with you
over the course of my whole life.
But one time I did when I was 15 with this girl that I dated,
we,
she was a,
she,
it was her idea.
And my friend Josh,
we all three of us got high together and I was probably like 1514 maybe 1415 and
I stole my dad's.
We'd had some super strong weed,
man.
I mean it was,
I don't,
I mean I was a little kid,
right?
And I don't know,
we smoked it.
I don't remember anything.
But what I do remember is just lying on the couch.
My whole body just tangling,
like little electrical circuits are going off and my whole body,
and then I was time traveling.
I would,
I would be on my back on the couch and then boom,
I'd be in front of the refrigerator and I had no recollection of how I got
there.
It was like instantly I appeared in front of the refrigerator and then boom,
I was in the bedroom and I couldn't remember walking into the bedroom.
It's like my short term memory was so fucked that every few steps,
my whole brain just rebooted.
And I'm like,
how'd I get here?
It erased all the steps up to get to that point.
There was no memory.
I mean,
my brain was fucked.
We were both fucked.
Gago giggling that I was scared of weed after that for awhile.
I didn't do it again for for a long time.
That was a,
that was a scary one.
Yeah
man.
I couldn't believe that people could function and smoke weed.
I didn't get it guys in the bands that I was in growing up,
it was always one stoner or two stoners and every time he made a mistake playing
bass,
I'll be like,
blame the,
we'd go see you come in here and fucking stone that fucking weed just fucks your
brain up.
Cause you know,
that's what I would do with Andy Dick on news radio.
Really?
They would come in high and he wouldn't remember his lyrics.
Sunblock.
The freak is high again.
I could be all pissed.
I was totally mad.
I was such a dick to stoners growing up.
Me Too.
How was it Dick?
I was fully,
you're addicted people.
I'm sorry.
You're,
you're addicted.
The people that you're afraid of yourself being,
you know,
I was afraid of being a stoner.
Will you say?
I just say,
I was watching cops last night and I was thinking about in the future when
marijuana will probably be legal.
Uh,
and so this officer was just going off on this girl for having some weed.
Like it was,
you know,
like maybe a quarter or something like that.
But it was going off just like go on,
you know how I can't believe this weed and boom.
And I was thinking,
how silly is this video going to look like in 10 years when we'd completely
legal and it's like normal and everything.
Like you're going to look back at how this cop was going.
Fucking ape shit on something that's like vitamins.
I wonder if we'd is going to be legal in 10 years.
I mean,
I would like to think it would be,
but honestly I'm not sure.
Because if you go back to like the 1970s hunter s Thompson was given speeches at
universities and shit and they were talking about legalization of marijuana and
you know,
he's like,
oh,
it's inevitable.
Maybe a doctor.
That's what he said,
like maybe a decade,
maybe we'll know.
Maybe never man,
2011 illegal in all the shit we know now.
The fact that it's illegal now is absolutely
partially it flies in the face of science,
flies in the face of logic.
There's no reason for them to be,
to be protecting us from it.
The only reason to keep it legal at this point is there's two reasons.
One,
because you don't want to ever admit you were wrong and let all those people out
of jail that you locked up for it.
And two,
what is the two?
Uh,
don't fart in the bathtub.
No,
there's no,
there's no other,
I don't know what the second,
my second point was.
There's no logical reason you have to be bought and paid by the pharmaceutical
companies.
So that's the only,
that's the only logical reason either you don't want to admit that you,
you know,
you fucked up in the past.
You don't want to re phrase the laws because then you open up this conundrum of
you being guilty of walking people in jail for something that's not really a
crime.
It's either that or you're being bought and paid for them.
Somebody is paying to make sure that you don't have these things legal cause
it's clear that you're not protecting anybody.
But we've come a long way though.
We have in California,
Spencer's and 14 other states too.
I've been able to read about people getting arrested left and right though on
Twitter.
People always send me things about like some high school kid gets arrested for
weed and I was doing three years in jail.
You know,
you hear about this shit.
It's still happening in the country.
It's becoming more and more illegal,
but every now and then you've got little dips like,
oh,
it's going to be hard.
It is hard.
But in California we'll never go back.
You know what I'm using as a model though?
I'm using this occupy Wall Street.
It's hard to stop this occupy Wall Street,
but boy are they fucking trying.
They're getting violent.
The getting violent about it.
And you see this Uc Davis footage or these cops spraying these pepper spray
spraying this shitness kids face,
all of them,
little kids at point blank range.
It's seeing them jabbing people with Bhutan's like
they are reacting.
But all these officers are getting in trouble for it or I'll get,
yeah,
they're getting suspended and all this.
So I don't think it's crazy because I think they realized that everyone has
cameras that they have to follow some kind of rules because we're all gonna know
about it.
And like,
I would like to believe that.
But you know that Tony Bologna Guy,
that guy who a pepper sprayed those girls in New York,
like one of the first instances that guy only lost 10 vacation days,
10 paid vacation days.
That's it.
Like I should be fired.
There's no way you should be allowed to be a fucking cop.
And that's what you want to do to some girls.
Just pepper spray him in the face.
You've got them all corralled in one spot.
He use pepper spray him in the face is he is um,
an officer,
uh,
this is not to defend them or anything,
but he is an officer and he probably doesn't make a lot of money out.
Imagine 10 vacation days.
That's ridiculous.
But that is also a lot of money probably for him,
you know?
And so it is a lot of money.
It's a lot of money for him doing a job that he did not do well.
No,
no.
I'm just saying so it is a penalty.
Like you're,
if you're an officer,
you're not going to be like,
dude,
that is,
I'm not going to go crazy because I don't want to lose fucking 10 vacation days.
You know they're getting him the obviously fought.
The union must have fought to keep that guy in in position because that's the
only thing that makes sense.
It's like when you see shit like the guy that the guy at Uc Davis that pepper
sprayed those kids in the face.
I don't know what happened to him,
but there's no way that guy should ever be in charge ever of enforcing the law.
There's no way that guy could,
should ever call himself an officer of the piece.
There's a bunch of little kids.
They could be my daughters,
they could be my sons.
They're 1618 years old,
whatever the fuck they are,
and your,
your pepper sprayed him in the face.
Fuck you.
That's just disgusting.
I don't care if they weren't listening to you.
I don't care what you're doing is disgusting.
That's disgusting.
It's malicious,
it's sadistic.
You're,
you know what you're doing.
You're spraying them in the face to teach them a lesson.
You're inflicting pain on them to get them away from you and you think you're
being slick about it.
You think it's your job in the world says fuck you.
And that's why the world took that guy's picture and put it online and put his
online shops.
Yeah,
he's,
yeah,
he's a that guys.
That's a bad example.
You think I should do a pepper spray,
a fetish video where I just get sprayed by this girl with a,
it's not real pepper spray,
but I have to act like you're going to become a fetish porn star.
I just want to know because I don't think I continue to work with you in this
capacity.
You start doing rape fetish videos will get tied up in trunks due to five
pounds.
There's a real video you out there,
you're getting tied up and trunks.
Do you show them your ass for 400 bucks?
No,
but if there's anything porn about,
if it's just 30 minutes and he does fine Bonser for the podcast.
Okay.
That's what you need.
You don't need to be sticking your ass in the air and letting these guys duct
tape your mouth.
They're going to fuck you and they're going to say that you agreed to it because
you're not going to read the contract.
So in some fine line.
Oh yeah.
And we get to fucking ass.
It probably is like written in there and undo a bunch of legal Mumbo jumbo.
As long as the client understands that forcible anal sex is a big part of the
program.
Thanks.
Bye.
Just put death squad TV on it.
Yeah.
If I just make it and make my own.
Why don't you make videos?
Are you getting fucked in the ass?
So be worth a lot of money,
but no,
no assets and if you want to make money though,
there's a fetish there for people that like looking at people tied up.
Let's build,
I start my own fetish of just people getting tied up.
It made it really cool.
It's build it up slow.
Like we're starting up with that and then eventually we're going to go for the
big bucks.
We're going to have a guy.
Fuck you.
No,
no.
Come on.
We'd have a stunt need to go for the big bucks.
Okay.
Stun asshole asshole corpse.
Like bullied.
Get a court on King Kong 1930s claymation no,
we can do it like this.
Hold the patient.
Like the wide shot would be a dollar,
but the tight shot will be a girlfriend with a strap on.
They won't be able to tell.
You know what I'm saying?
You just,
it's all in editing.
I black girl don't feel like compromise the idea of doing these videos doesn't
it?
You don't think that people are gonna like get off on the idea you being taped
up and maybe want to find you a tape you up.
Uh,
yeah,
that's,
I never thought of that angle but that's a good thing.
It's definitely so I wouldn't do that one.
I would do stuff like just guys with a dirty nails.
No you should do.
You should do now just stepping pudding before.
What you should do is make one.
This is a no lose situation.
Make one where you shoot laser beams out of your eyes.
You stare at a girl in the eyes and it causes her to have to suck your Dick.
Then where everywhere you go,
girls won't want to talk to your deck.
Like there's no way that works.
Oh my God,
it does work.
The craziest girls would just immediately start blowing you.
He's,
he really does have hypnotic powers.
I do.
Can you just tell them that's,
that's,
that's what you do if you're smart or not.
This other fucking bondage thing holding him,
watching TV.
It's just you and a friend holding hands and watching TV,
but you're not doing anything else.
You're just holding each other's hand while watching some TV.
As long as you can like rub fingers and thumbs together.
Not just hold hands but caress him.
I didn't think of that.
Well,
what if I had a,
I had to wear white gloves if we were both wearing white gloves.
Hmm.
That's better for sure.
But yeah,
you just hold them white glove,
but maybe it feels even more gay because it's all slippery.
The cloth against the cloth,
put some cat litter in there until it feels uncomfortable the whole time you're
getting cut by those crystals.
Crystals,
you just ruin the whole thing.
Fuck.
Put it inside the glove so it's not comfortable.
Why?
Why do you want to do gay things on video for money?
I don't really know if someone offering you something.
No,
no,
I'm not.
I'm really not doing this.
I said,
so you gay Hustler,
Huh?
No,
I'm just thinking that.
I know there's a fetish there right now that uh,
I've seen that there's people that buy and there's people that are making money
off these crazy videos of nothing of guises.
I learned nothing,
man.
It's hard during wise.
Really?
Well we were talking about is not that stuff that you're talking about getting
tied up.
It's hard to find people that are into you being tied up and those people,
man and everything.
You don't want to work in that market.
Yeah,
I don't.
Yeah.
You don't want to be a common part of that mark.
Right.
You can be really famous in that in a nice white guy posters and shit and you
all tied up.
There's like posters and yeah,
you can be the number one guy that everybody wants to rape and you can be like,
you know,
you could be like the Traci lords of trunk rape,
Trump videos,
get stalkers.
I've been able to get a lot of Dexter fans.
I bet.
I Bet Michael C.
Hall has that.
Those fans like this creepy Guy Tiller fairs.
They are wonder man,
I wonder how many dudes out there want to be serial killers but they don't want
to go to jail.
So like Ah,
it's not worth it.
So they open up a Christian bookstore instead.
Christian books.
Yeah.
Just to fight it off like you to say like dudes do it like Ted Haggard to fight
off the gay.
They just go super,
super,
Super Christian to try to fight outside.
Most priests.
Yeah.
Most of them.
Maybe all of them.
Wouldn't that be crazy for the Catholic church really was just an organization
that kid fuckers,
I mean it was a cult in ancient cult of kid fuckers and they just slowly but
surely integrated their way into the cities and the common laws they are,
that raises Skilton control.
Well they used to do as well.
It wasn't always illegal for the priest to get laid.
Yeah.
They actually could have got land like most other denominations,
but they were getting too much personally.
They were like rock stars.
Like the dude's,
they were going to the church,
they were like hating on the priests because their wives wanted a bottom.
So people were leaving and then they decided,
you know what,
to save the church,
we gotta we gotta outlaw getting laid for these dudes.
Humanitarian can imagine what the priest at the time when they did,
when they were thinking about outline posey what they were thinking,
their lives are coming to a fucking halt.
Yeah.
They probably thought about the same way.
All those,
um,
Wall Street people start talking and when the,
when they started talking about cracking down on Wall Street.
Yeah.
Like do hard.
The party's over,
sir.
What parties over?
Yeah,
no,
there they're probably fighting.
It came out in the fucking priest.
They were fighting us going to the emperor.
But your highness please.
Why became a priest?
Yeah.
So then all those guys end up quitting.
Right.
They're like,
fuck that.
You know what I mean?
No more pussy.
Fuck.
They quit.
So the only guys that would take the job or dudes,
it didn't give a fuck about pussy.
What came through
first?
What came first?
The confession booth or where priests couldn't get pussy anymore,
which came first.
That's very important.
Kidding him.
Pussy of course.
You think so.
That came first and the confession booth came
after that.
Definitely.
Really?
Yeah.
Hmm.
I wonder in the confession booth for little kids,
probably like the plastic container of a fleshlight.
Maybe they really tried to keep it together and for a while they just beat off
in their white girls told crazy fuck stories.
They go,
yeah,
you know what?
The law,
the policy first,
but they let I go,
you know what?
We got to come up with something else.
Beat off,
beat up.
That's why they had crazy robes.
You can use this loads just disappear under those things.
Yeah.
The first time I was going to catechism and that's like school to train,
how to be a Catholic,
you know what I mean?
I'm a kid and they told us about confession,
we got to go to confession and I was like fuck.
I mean I was thinking,
am I going to have to talk about me playing with myself?
You know what I mean?
Like that was a big concern because I really believed that this priest had
connections with God and now God's gonna find out that I'm beating out.
So that was a big concern.
And I asked my catechism teacher,
I'm like,
cause cause you're supposed to say all your sins and then the PN please God
forgive me for all of these sins and all my other past sins,
like the ones you couldn't remember.
So I asked him,
I asked my catechism,
teacher would have,
I don't say I leave one of my sins out.
Could that part at the end cover it for like these and all my other sins when
she goes,
nope.
If you remember it,
you got to say it.
I'm like,
oh Jesus,
how the fuck am I going to confess?
Playing with myself?
I didn't call it beating off.
We didn't call it jerk and office,
like playing with myself.
I was like eight years old going,
fuck,
this is going to be hard.
So I practiced that shit and I went,
I just want her to fucking blaze right through it,
right over it and not hesitate.
So I'm like,
you know,
hi.
It's been,
it's,
you know,
this is my first confession.
These are my sins.
I stole a candy bar.
I yelled at my brother,
I lied to my mom.
I played with myself.
I cheated on a homework and you know,
I'd be,
I just like go right over here,
put it in the room.
I was hoping you wouldn't ask them.
I like,
I was hoping he wouldn't go.
Wait a minute,
back up a little bit there.
What do you mean by playing with yourself?
Like,
Oh,
that was my nightmare and he did.
They never,
they never asked me to explain myself.
He didn't.
Oh,
he did good.
He didn't do too.
What a panic it would be if that's the only one he picked up on.
What you did want?
What is paid with deals?
What does that mean?
Explain yourself described to me and good.
Yeah.
No,
you hear the clank of glass on aluminum as he unscrews whose job?
Absolutely.
Hold on,
hold on,
hold on.
Back Up.
Hold on one second.
One Sec.
What did you do in detail?
In detail?
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
I'm not going to talk.
I just want to hear you play with yourself so well.
I was alone in the tub and I just was watching it and it felt so good.
I didn't want to stop washing it and next thing you know I wasn't,
I wasn't even watching it anymore.
I was just cause it was a sinful,
it was just for pleasure.
Why did you do man?
My Dick was so small back then when I started playing with myself I couldn't
like beat all,
you know,
like jerk off like like you normally do.
I like rubbed
my hands together.
Yes.
I would like,
like I was starting a fire on my little Peter.
Uh,
yeah man,
that's the way jerked off.
It's hilarious.
What do you call it now?
Eddie jerking off?
No,
I mean you're Peter,
do you have a name?
Um,
Mike,
you don't have like a name for it?
No,
it doesn't need a name.
Do you have a name for your day?
No,
but I think I want to name it now.
Now that you,
right now you have to call your Dixon.
I want to call it little Conan little cone and little Conan the barbarian.
I have a feeling that that's already fucking video
guy.
I'm the guy who has the,
um,
the,
the face in his crotch.
There's a bunch of people that have faces in their crotches
no,
what are you talking about?
The big bad wolf of unit.
Yeah,
I watched it.
That was fucking hilarious.
Bizarre.
Is that,
is that one of the most bizarre things ever?
Yeah.
Can you mentioned sh Shermaine yeah,
look at,
look,
look it up online.
It's a video on youtube called the big bad wolf.
Have you seen it?
You haven't seen it Eddie.
It's fucking awesome.
Should we play it?
I don't know if we could get in trouble with that.
Yeah.
Is it somebody's sketch?
Something like that.
Base for maybe made it go look at it.
Look,
find it online cause it's fucking hilarious.
I didn't want to tell you what it is.
Just more bazaar.
So good.
Wow.
That's a cool thing about,
you know online.
All you have to do is put something out there and if it's good it will spread.
You know everything spreads.
That video of Joey Diaz crashing through the thing.
It didn't work.
It didn't come through for you.
I know I'm going to have to,
you tried to download it on your phone.
It didn't work.
Did you try to download it on a computer?
Nudity though,
right?
Yes.
It's doing Joey Diaz his balls.
Well we have to do is blur that out.
Yeah,
it's an old video man.
If you've seen a Eddie,
oh we can't play it on this.
That's why we can play it.
Which one?
Joey Diaz.
When he comes crashing through that picture and he's naked except for a baseball
hat and to,
to fucking
timberland boots on.
Right.
Yeah.
Let's get this party started.
You gotta take it down?
Yeah,
but we found it.
But that last,
it used it for your website then?
Yeah,
it was on [inaudible] website for awhile.
We got to remove that.
Yeah,
they got mad at me with some of the stuff that I put up my website.
Did you have to take anything else don,
that you remember?
Like I don't really know of you taking anything.
Yeah.
There was a bunch of pictures with Joey and a slut.
So some wild creature.
Yeah.
It was just as good.
It was bizarre.
It was like all of a sudden.
What,
what kind of a site do I have here?
He hated that.
That old Joe showed the porn one with your friend Mike St pier or what's his
name?
The one uh,
Joe Show we did with your Pardot friend guy that Michael St Pierre or rolly
Steven Saint Croix guys used to come to the comic store all the time.
Michael Saint Pierre Making Shit Up.
I knew it was three names.
He's a good dude.
A lot of those guys would come down to the comedy store.
Comments towards a magnet for strange people.
Right.
Fuck Hollywood
in itself.
It's weird.
As I got older,
when I think about how crazy and chaotic Hollywood really is,
I couldn't imagine living there.
It's so strange.
You lived in West Hollywood forever,
Dude.
I don't know how you did it.
I remember Robert Appalachia.
Yeah,
it was that guy's name.
Robert [inaudible].
He's still alive.
Yeah.
That's comedy still.
Still hates lasers.
Yeah.
I thinks lasers are Nazis coming together.
Five minutes.
We've got to wrap this pitch up.
A Eddie,
where can,
uh,
what's your,
your latest seminars?
Oh,
and if anybody's into Jujitsu,
listen,
we're offering,
we're doing a special here where if you go to legends and sign up for Jujitsu in
Hollywood,
it's a east of the one on one on Santa Monica Boulevard.
What his exact address?
51 76 Santa Monica Boulevard.
It's a 10 51 76 Santa Monica Boulevard.
Yeah.
It's legends MMA and I teach the Jujitsu that that's the headquarters for 10th
Planet Jiu Jitsu and the deal we got going on right now mentioned the podcast.
I'm desperate for new customers.
Mention the podcast,
signed a six month contract and get the first two months free so you only have
to pay for four months.
You get two months of free Jujitsu,
enjoy the shit out of it.
And uh,
listen,
there's a beginner classes,
you don't have to worry.
You're going to be doing it with people that are just starting out just like
you.
And it's really fun.
It's way more fun than just any other kind of regular exercise because you're
doing something,
it's like,
it's exciting.
I look forward to playing a video game,
but a virtual reality video game.
You are practicing killing techniques he has.
No one gets hurt.
No one's striking.
You're just practicing choking each other.
You know,
everybody in there,
we're all bros.
It's like it's,
it's,
yeah,
we tap each other out and then we're cool.
Yeah,
it happens all the time.
Got Hurt.
It's,
it's a great power to have.
It's a great skill to have the skill to get subdue people and put them asleep or
to,
you know,
run drum,
cripple for a temporary temporarily.
At least it's,
it's a great skill,
but have it so much fun.
We got beginner classes.
You don't have to be super smart or anything.
We have total retards that kids do it.
Old Ladies do it.
It's so much fun.
You gotta work out.
Everyone has to work out.
You might as well do something that's Super Fun,
Super Fun.
And it's a good skill to have.
You know,
if you had to choose between his riding a fucking elliptical machine every day
and lifting weights every now and then,
that's going to get boring.
Yeah.
This is like a skill.
It's a skill,
a life skill that can really help you.
If someone's fucking with you,
something happens.
They could save your life.
You know,
you're getting addicted to video games.
There's not going to save your life.
Playing Golf isn't going to save your life.
Lifting weights can help and saving your life,
but Jujitsu that really can save your life.
You and I both,
when we lift weights,
we lift weights just to get stronger at Jujitsu.
You know,
there's guys who live weights to look good and do like bicep curls,
like they work on certain specific things to look good.
I don't,
I don't do anything that doesn't help Jujitsu.
That's all I need to do.
And when you do that too,
I mean it all falls
into place,
you know,
and then you,
you start using your body as one unit two instead of like the bodybuilding style
of isolating things.
I don't hardly isolate anything anymore.
Every workout I do is like big cleans and you know,
and,
and squats and Kettlebell routines and shit.
Everything uses the whole body.
And the only reason why I do it is to get better at Jujitsu.
Yeah.
Well that's,
that's where we met 97 at John Jacques Machado Academy and a in the valley doing
Jujitsu.
And you know,
we had that one thing in common.
We're both obsessed with learning how to put people to sleep.
It's so much fun.
Yeah.
Martial arts,
man.
I just,
uh,
I think every young man should learn martial arts and not just to be a fighter,
to learn about yourself,
you know,
just to,
to push yourself to put yourself into difficult situations where you're nervous
and to overcome it and to learn from failure and you know,
so important man for development of your character.
So important for shaping your worldview and relaxing you as a person.
You know,
it's not what everybody thinks it is,
man.
It's not like a bunch of people trying to be bad asses.
It's not,
it's not at all.
It's not.
It's really cool people.
Some of my favorite human beings are my friends from martial arts,
guys that are trained with,
you know,
some of my favorite human beings,
some of the most relaxed people I know.
Some of the easiest going have the ego under control,
just super kind,
friendly people.
My favorite image search of right away
do also to do,
I got,
I'm going to be in Melbourne,
Australia December 3rd that may be sold out,
I'm not sure.
And then New Zealand,
December 4th,
December 3rd Melbourne December 4th New Zealand.
I think their spots still open for New Zealand in Hamilton,
New Zealand I think.
And then December 17th in Springfield,
I'm doing a seminar that's a free seminar.
As long as you bring a gift,
a gift wrap,
a gift for a Christmas drive that we're doing.
So free seminar,
10 planet Springfield December 17th also tonight,
the movie that I did with Joey karate and hand out the,
we're putting it on my youtube channel tonight at midnight,
youtube.com/twist already.
And um,
if you want to listen to my music,
reverb.reverbnation.com/smoke serpent.
So,
uh,
I don't know how many tickets are left for this show tonight,
if any is a quartered to nine right now while we're wrapping this up.
And the show starts at 10 30 so it's still a long time from now.
If you're interested,
uh,
go to the Ice House website and find the number and call.
And tonight we got bill Burr,
we got Joey Diaz,
we got,
who else?
Brian [inaudible],
Steve.
Oh,
Brendan Walsh.
It's a Goddamn stellar lineup.
Please gentlemen in me,
I'll be there too.
And thank you everybody.
Thanks for tuning in.
Thank you to the fleshlight.
Go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for the fleshlight entering the code
name.
Rogan get 15% off the number one sex toy for men product that we have all use
and endorse.
Uh,
thank you to [inaudible] dot com o n I t checkout all the various supplements
that we have for sale there.
We have a Alpha brain,
which is a cognitive enhancing supplement.
We have shroom tech sport,
which is a quarter steps mushroom endurance supplement.
That's great for people to work out really hard.
Um,
new moon is a five HTP and l trip to fan,
um,
uh,
supplement that just makes you feel groovy.
All right,
go get that.
Go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the Onnit link and during the codename Rogan and you'll get 10% off.
That's it.
Thanks everybody.
Thank you.
We'll see you next week with a,
God knows who.
I think we've got some crazy people lined up,
right Brian?
Yes,
yes.
We do follow a desk squad on iTunes and uh,
thank you for everything.
We love you.
You,
you've Buchan dirty bitches
love.
Yeah.